Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und das hier ist die 123.
Ausgabe von Raumzeit. Nach einer kleinen Pause geht es wieder weiter bei der
Erkundung des Weltalls.
Und genau das tun wir heute auch. Heute hat mich der Weg geführt nach Göttingen.
Hier war ich schon mal am Max-Planck-Institut für Sonnensysteme in Göttingen
und begrüße meinen heutigen Gesprächspartner, Paul Hartoch.
Hallo.
Herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Paul, du bist schon ganz lange hier, habe ich gehört.
Ja, ich meine länger als das Institut hier in Göttingen ist.
Wir waren früher im Vorharz in Kattelund-Bürich-Linder, so 25 Kilometer nordöstlich
von Göttingen. und sind vor zehn Jahren hingezogen ins neue Gebäude.
Ach echt? Erst vor zehn Jahren?
Erst vor zehn Jahren, 2014. Das Institut heißt seit 2004 MPI für Sonnensystemforschung.
Vorher hieß es MPI für Aeronomie, also sozusagen die Wissenschaft der mittleren und oberen Atmosphäre.
Und warum der Schwenk zu dem globaleren Namen?
Ich glaube, das war, also früher hat das Institut sich hauptsächlich mit der
Erdatmosphäre beschäftigt und irgendwann war das halt so eine Art Strategiewechsel.
Also das hat wahrscheinlich damit zu tun gehabt, dass einige der Mitarbeiter,
also zum Beispiel Stratosphärenwissenschaftler, dann die Möglichkeiten hatten,
an Weltraummissionen teilzunehmen. Und so hat sich das einfach im Laufe der Zeit entwickelt.
Es gab damals ja diese Giotto-Mission zum Halligen Kometen,
dann gab es Helios, Sonnenmission und so ist das Institut dann immer weiter
praktisch in Weltraummissionen reingewachsen und hat dann irgendwann die Idee gehabt,
die Forschungsrichtung von Aeronomie in Sonnensystemforschung umzuändern.
Und mittlerweile machen wir auch so gut wie keine Aeronomie mehr,
noch ein ganz bisschen. Ein Kollege macht das noch.
Aber ja, es ist also tatsächlich jetzt sehr breit aufgestellt.
Okay, ja, das ist auch ganz gut so, denn heute soll es ja gehen um den Jupiter.
Ich hatte ja hier bei Raumzeit schon so das eine oder andere Planetchen unseres
Sonnensystems vorgestellt und da klaffte die ganze Zeit so eine Lücke.
Also ich muss jetzt da mal nachrechnen.
Wir hatten jetzt glaube ich Merkur und Venus und Mars sind alle schon dran gewesen
und auch über das Saturn-System haben wir schon gesprochen.
Für die äußeren Planeten gibt es sozusagen noch offene Bewerbung,
aber ja, heute muss unbedingt mal der Jupiter dran kommen.
Beziehungsweise würde ich halt von vornherein vom Jupiter-System sprechen,
weil das einfach so eine komplexe Angelegenheit ist im Vergleich zu den anderen Planeten.
Jupiter, auch irgendwie so ein bisschen der König der Planeten, könnte man fast sagen.
Zumindest der größte und massereichste, das kann man also durchaus sagen.
Ja und auch ein Planet, der sehr wichtig ist für die Entstehung des Sonnensystems,
eben aufgrund seiner hohen Schwerkraft hat er die Entstehung des Sonnensystems
oder die heutige Form des Sonnensystems also mitgeprägt.
Zum Beispiel, dass Mars kleiner ist als die Erde.
Nach gewissen Theorien hätte Erde, Venus, Mars etwa gleich große Masse haben sollen.
Da gibt es ja diese sogenannte Grand Tech Theorie und so weiter und so fort.
Aber das ist ein abendfüllendes Thema. Da wollte ich jetzt nicht weiter drauf eingehen.
Naja gut, ein Podcast ist ja auch ein abendfüllendes Thema. Wie ist dein Verhältnis zum Film 2001?
Da spielt der Jupiter ja eine besondere Rolle.
Ja, also insofern ein bisschen unwissenschaftlich, als wahrscheinlich die Masse
des Jupiters nicht ausreicht, um halt so eine Kernfusion zu zünden.
Aber ja, ist natürlich ein sehr interessanter Film, ein Klassiker.
Kubrick, der hat ja einige interessante Filme gemacht und ich fand den ganz
gut mit diesem Computer, Hale und so weiter und so fort.
Und ja, teilweise sind natürlich Ideen aus den 60er Jahren schon von der Truppe
um Werner von Braun da realisiert worden, die dann in der Praxis nachher nie
realisiert wurden, weil sie doch zu teuer waren.
Aber konzeptionell fand ich das also sehr interessant, so wie sich das damals vorgestellt hat.
Und man könnte es heutzutage natürlich immer noch machen, wenn man die entsprechenden
Ressourcen, Startmassen und so weiter hat.
Ja, naja gut, mal schauen, ob wir dann da auch so einen Monolithen entdecken,
falls wir da mal ein bisschen genau nachschauen.
Hat man noch nicht gefunden.
Oder Jupiter. Na gut, ich scherze.
Ja, vielleicht erstmal so ein bisschen zu dir. Also du hast ja schon angedeutet,
bist ja schon sehr lange hier, du hast glaube ich mit dem Physikstudium begonnen,
sozusagen die Wissenschaft so einzusteigen.
Wahrscheinlich hast du vorher schon angefangen mit Wissenschaft, oder?
Ja, ich kann mich erinnern, ich glaube zum achten Geburtstag hat mir jemand
so dieses Buch Was ist was?
Planeten und Raumfahrt geschenkt. Und das fand ich damals ganz interessant.
Bin dann aber als Schüler dann in andere Sachen so ein bisschen abgedriftet.
Elektronik, Hochfrequenztechnik und so weiter, Chemie.
Da hat man damals Schwarzpulver und irgendwelche Sprengstoffe gemacht.
Bin dann, eigentlich wollte erst Elektrotechnik studieren, Hochfrequenztechnik, Nachrichtentechnik.
Bin dann aber doch wieder nach Diskussion mit einigen Freunden,
die auch das eine oder das andere halt Physik studierten, im Endeffekt dann
doch zur Physik gekommen und habe dann in Göttingen Physik studiert.
Auch weil ich ein paar Freunde hatte, die Physik studiert hatten und bin dann
per Zufall wieder in diese Richtung Planeten- und Raumfahrt gekommen, muss man sagen.
Zufall. Zufall, ja. Also ich bin an das damalige Institut für Aeronomie gekommen,
eben über mein Interesse an Nachrichtentechnik, Wellenausbreitung,
Nachrichtenübermittlung.
Die machten damals unter anderem Junosphärenforschung, da gab es in Göttingen
eine Vorlesung, Einführung in die Physik der Junosphäre und da sind dann so
gewisse Interessengruppen da reingegangen von Studenten,
haben diese Vorlesung sich angehört und so kriegte man halt Kontakte und so
bin ich dann auch irgendwie an das Institut gekommen und wollte auch in diese Richtung was machen.
Allerdings zur damaligen Zeit war es so, da gab es ein Großprojekt,
das hieß Ice Card European Inquiry and Scatter, oben in Norwegen,
Schweden und Finnland und das funktionierte nicht so richtig.
Und als ich da damals dann anfing als Student oder anfangen wollte,
Sagt dann der entsprechende Betreuer, nee, ich nehme jetzt keine Diplomarbeiten
mehr an, ich soll mich mal anderweitig umgucken. Da habe ich mich im Institut
anderweitig umgeguckt.
Und da gab es damals ein neues Projekt, das hieß Millimeterwellenatmosphärensondierer.
Das war also praktisch ein Projekt, das vorgesehen war, auf einem Space Shuttle
zu fliegen, um die mittlere Atmosphäre der Erde, also die Stratosphäre und die
Mesosphäre zu analysieren.
Schwerpunkt war damals auch die Ozonforschung in den 80er Jahren.
Und da war meine Aufgabe dann ein sogenanntes Vielkanal-Spektrometer-Backend
zu entwickeln. Mal zu gucken, was es da so gibt.
Zur damaligen Zeit hat man da sogenannte Filterbänke verwendet.
Ein was? Ein Field?
Ein Vielkanal. Also wie viel und Kanal? Vielkanal-Spektrometer.
Also man muss sich vorstellen, früher hat man die Spektren in dieser Messtechnik
dadurch gemessen, indem man einfach verschiedene Bandpassfilter,
die immer einen bestimmten Frequenzbereich abgedeckt haben, parallel geschaltet hat.
Schmalbandige Filter, wenn man hohe Auflösungen haben wollte,
breitbandige Filter, wenn man große Bandbreiten überdecken wollte im Spektrum.
Und die Dinger, die waren halt relativ schwer und aufwendig kompliziert zu bauen.
Typischerweise hatte so eine Filterbank dann vielleicht 50 bis 100 Kanäle,
um so einen Spektralbereich abzudecken.
Das reichte meistens auch nicht
aus, um die Linien, die man da beobachten wollte, komplett zu samplen.
Also gemeint sind jetzt die Absorptionslinien, mit denen man quasi herausfinden kann.
Was… Oder Emissionslinien zum Beispiel, in dem Fall Ozon.
Um herauszufinden, was ist da oben.
Genau. Damals war das so bei diesen Millimeterwellenatmosphären-Sondierer,
dass man Ozon, Wasserdampf, Chlormonoxid und Sauerstoff O2 messen wollte.
Und ja, damals ist tatsächlich so eine Filterbank auch zum Einsatz gekommen.
Und die hatte dann doch ein relativ imposanter Ausmaße oder Abmessung,
sodass das Ding immer als Kindersarg betitelt wurde.
Und meine Aufgabe war es dann, etwas Neues, eine neue Technologie zu entwickeln,
die halt viel kleiner war und die sozusagen mit vielleicht einem Zehntel oder
Fünfzigstel des Volumens dreimal so viel oder zehnmal so viele Kanäle hat.
Und das war dann meine Diplomarbeit und im Prinzip die Anwendung dessen war
dann meine Doktorarbeit und so bin ich dann auch in die Atmosphärenforschung
gekommen, durch die Anwendung.
So, jetzt hast du ja hier verschiedene Hüter auf.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe, also
ein bisschen Leiter der Gruppe Planetare Atmosphären, hier so heißt das.
Und außerdem bist du jetzt auch richtig engagiert bei der Mission Juice,
die wir hier schon mal in Raumzeit Nummer 95 besprochen haben,
als ich in Madrid mit dem Mission Manager Nicolas Altobelli gesprochen habe,
über die Mission und was die Ziele der Mission sind.
Und konkret bist du PI, also Principal Investigator.
Man muss immer seine Abkürzung am Start haben.
Für das Submillimeter Wave Instrument SWI auf diese JUICE-Satelliten.
Wahrscheinlich mit dem Ziel, dort auch mal ganz ordentlich die Atmosphären durchzuklopfen
vom Jupiter und den ganzen Kollegen.
Ja, kann man so sagen.
Man könnte jetzt den Sprung machen von Millimeterwellenatmosphärensondierer
Ende der 80er Jahre oder geflogen ist es glaube ich Anfang der 90er,
ich glaube 91, 92, ich kann mich gar nicht mehr so genau erinnern,
zu dieser Mission eigentlich das gleiche Prinzip.
Nur, was sich im Laufe der Zeit geändert hat, dass man immer neue Wellenlängenbereiche
des elektromagnetischen Spektrums erschlossen hat. Das heißt,
man ist zu immer höheren Frequenzen gegangen.
Während man damals sowas bei 100, 200 Gigahertz war, ist man jetzt eben über
1000 Gigahertz bis 1280 Gigahertz.
Und es ist so, dass dieser hohe Frequenzbereich für einen gewissen Temperaturbereich
der Atmosphären eben von sehr großer Bedeutung ist.
Und gerade für Jupiter ist es eben auch sehr wichtig, dass man tatsächlich in
diesem Terahertz-Bereich oberhalb von einem Terahertz, also oberhalb von 1000
Gigahertz oder einer Million Megahertz sozusagen,
also 10 hoch 12 Hertz messen kann, was technologisch extrem anspruchsvoll ist.
Warum ist das wichtig? Also was heißt wichtig in dem Zusammenhang?
Ja, einfach weil die, wenn man sich die Spektren der Moleküle anschaut,
ist es einfach so, dass in dem Bereich sehr, sehr viele Molekülspektren vorkommen,
die auch zum Teil eben sehr hohen Absorptionsquerschnitt haben,
also sehr starke Linien.
Und wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel ein Spurengas anschaut, das nur in ganz geringen
Mengen vorhanden ist, dann ist das von Vorteil, wenn man halt einen sehr starken
Übergang, eine sehr starke Linie von diesem Spurengas sieht,
weil sonst alles im Rauschen halt verschwinden würde.
Was könnte das für ein Gas sein, jetzt mal so als Beispiel?
Ja, damals beim MRS zum Beispiel war das Chlormonoxid, CLO, das ist eine relativ
schwache Linie, auch deswegen, weil es relativ wenig vorkommt.
Und da versucht man sich dann Übergänge anzuschauen, die eben stark sind.
Also zur damaligen Zeit war das glaube ich 204 Gigahertz.
Und ein paar Jahre später haben wir dann durch weitere technologische Entwicklungen
in den Submillimeterwellenbereich, das war glaube ich 649 Gigahertz,
eine Linie gesehen, die dann schon zehnmal so stark war, die wir dann vom Flugzeug ausgemessen haben.
Problem ist, vom Erdboden kann man diese Messungen nicht machen,
weil die Unteratmosphäre, also die Troposphäre, insbesondere der Wasserdampf,
aber teilweise auch Ozon und Sauerstoff eben dazu führen, dass die Strahlung
aus den oberen Stockwerken der Erdatmosphäre nicht so gut empfangen werden kann.
Es sei denn, man geht auf einen hohen Berg.
Das ist ja auch in der Radioastronomie der Fall, dass man möglichst hoch geht,
sodass praktisch die Störungen durch die unteren Atmosphäre so gering wie möglich sind.
Wenn da jetzt nicht die ganzen Satelliten rumkurven würden, die einem Ärger machen.
Ja, also die sieht man meistens nicht, weil die Beams dann doch zu groß sind.
Aber in der Radioastronomie ist das meistens kein Problem, wobei ich jetzt gehört habe, dass...
Ich glaube, mit dem Starlink-Netzwerk haben Sie dann doch Ihre liebe Mühe gehabt.
Ja, ja, hatte ich gehört, dass Sie irgendwelche Störungen im Bereich von zwei
Meter Wellenlänge machen.
Und wobei jetzt bei den neueren Satelliten das wohl schon wieder am Abgestellten ist.
Ich würde gerne nochmal, vielleicht mal so einen kleinen Exkurs nochmal machen,
warum das so wichtig ist.
Weil ich habe so das Gefühl, wir werden da jetzt sehr viel drüber reden.
Und auch wenn das hier immer wieder
mal angeklungen ist, ist es glaube ich nochmal ganz wert zu vertiefen.
Diese Sache mit den Spektren und der Absorption oder der Emission.
Also man will ja heraus, deswegen fliegen wir ja dahin, wir wollen ja herausfinden,
was ist da. Woraus besteht das? Was ist wo?
Man möchte gerne diesen Planeten und die Monde maximal durchleuchten und herausfinden,
welche chemischen Vorgänge sind dort, welche Eigenschaften hat diese gesamte
Atmosphäre, hat dieser Planet.
Und um das jetzt abzutasten, will man halt Spektren auswerten.
Spektren heißt, man strahlt quasi rein oder man empfängt das, was abgestrahlt wird,
empfängt man, löst es möglichst fein in seine Frequenzbestandteile auf.
Und dann kann man halt rausfinden, was da genau ist, weil einfach jedes,
ich weiß nicht, kann man sagen, jedes Molekül hat seine eigene...
Sozusagen sein eigenes Muster in diesem Spektrum, an dem man es genau erkennen
kann. Also gilt das wirklich für jedes Molekül?
Also kann man wirklich jedes Molekül von jedem anderen Molekül immer genau unterscheiden,
wenn man überhaupt erstmal die richtige Frequenz analysiert?
Oder gibt es da auch so Sachen, wo man sagt, naja, kann das sein, kann das sein?
Ja, im Sonnensystem wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber im interstellaren Medium ist
es tatsächlich so, dass es teilweise so viele verschiedene Moleküle und Linien gibt.
Das interstellaren Medium ist natürlich auch riesig ausgedehnt und ich habe
da diese Molekülwolken und gucke da über tausende von Lichtjahren und wenn ich
mit dem Radioteleskop da durchschaue, sehe ich natürlich alles auf dem Mal.
Und da ist es schon wichtig, dass man tatsächlich mit extrem hoher spektraler
Auflösung arbeitet, damit man die Linie noch voneinander unterscheiden kann,
dass man da wirklich mit 10 hoch 7 spektraler Auflösung meinetwegen arbeitet,
weil man sonst im sogenannten,
das ist ein Fachausdruck in der Radiostromie, Confusion Limit arbeitet.
Das heißt, man kann die Linie dann irgendwann nicht mehr unterscheiden,
weil es da tatsächlich so viele gibt.
Das kommt allerdings im Sonnensystem eher nicht vor. Wir haben jetzt einen Erdvorbeiflug
gemacht, gerade im August letzten Jahres, Nee, diesen Jahres, sorry, letzten Monat.
Mit Juice? Mit Juice, genau, da gab es das.
Die ist ja jetzt gestartet, ist auf dem Weg zum Jupiter, aber muss sich natürlich
erst noch ein paar Mal Schwung holen, unter anderem auch an der Erde.
Und das ist dann eben die Gelegenheit, auch mal auf die Erde zu schauen.
Genau, das gibt praktisch drei Erdvorbeiflüge, ein Venusvorbeiflug,
um sich Schwung zu holen. Und der letzte Erdvorbeiflug findet 2029 statt.
Und dann fliegt der Satellit innerhalb von zwei Jahren zum Jupiter,
mit entsprechend hoher Geschwindigkeit.
Und diesmal wurde erstmalig so eine Art Doppelmanöver gemacht,
dass man zunächst am Mond und dann an der Erde vorbeigeflogen ist,
sonst hat man nur einen Erdvorbeiflug gehabt das nannte sich halt Lega Luna Earth Gravity Assist,
und ja, da waren einige Leute dann bei der J.M.O.G.
Juice Mission Operations Center ein bisschen bange, ob das wohl alles gut funktionieren
würde, hat es aber und naja, bei der Gelegenheit haben wir dann unser Instrument auch eingeschaltet,
um es das kalibrieren zu können und zu gucken, ob die ganzen wissenschaftlichen
Beobachtungsmodi auch funktionieren, so wie wir uns das vorstellen.
Und ja, da haben wir uns eben auch die Erdatmosphäre angeschaut und wir waren
wirklich erstaunt oder beeindruckt, wie viele Linien man tatsächlich in einigen
von diesen Submillimeterbändern sieht.
Gerade im hohen Frequenzbereich, also zwischen 1065 und 1280 GHz,
das ist also der obere Submillimeterwellenkanal, da waren zum Teil 25 Ozonlinien
in einem Tuning, in einem Durchlassbereich des Spektrometers.
Das ist eigentlich, wenn man in diesem Metier arbeitet, eher ungewöhnlich.
Da hat man meistens so ein, zwei, vielleicht drei Linien und wenn man plötzlich
25 sieht, das ist dann schon eine andere Liga.
Das Besondere ist jetzt, um das nochmal zu betonen, das Instrument ist ja eigentlich
gedacht für den Jupiter, aber ist jetzt quasi an der Erde vorbeigeflogen,
hat sich die Erde angeschaut und es gab bisher noch nicht so einen Blick auf die Erde,
weil das Instrument so noch nicht existierte.
Zumindest nicht in diesem Wellenlängenbereich, da um 250 Mikrometer oder sagen
wir mal 1100 bis 1300 Gigahertz.
Also es gibt durchaus Satelliten, die bei der halben Frequenz oder bei der doppelten
Wellenlänge im 600 Gigahertz Bereich die Erde routinemäßig beobachten.
Die dann speziell auf Linien wie zum Beispiel Ozon oder Moleküllinien,
die für den Ozonabbau verantwortlich sind, schauen oder auf den Wasserdampf,
der auch sehr wichtig ist in der mittleren Atmosphäre.
Aber in diesem Frequenzbereich sind noch keine Beobachtungen mit eben dieser
sehr hohen Auflösung von 10 Millionen gemacht worden.
Und von daher haben wir zum ersten Mal sozusagen die Spektren der Erde in diesem
Wellenlängenbereich sehen können bei diesem Vorbeiflug.
Und ja, viele Leute in meinem Team, die arbeiten schon seit 10,
20, 30 Jahren teilweise auf diesem Gebiet und die waren alle hellauf begeistert, das zu sehen.
Ich glaube, für den normalen Menschen vielleicht gar nicht so interessant,
Aber für denjenigen, der sich mit Spektroskopie beschäftigt,
ist das dann doch schon ein ganz besonderes Ereignis.
Da macht man schon mal eine Pülle Shampoos auf, wenn sowas passiert, oder?
Ja, ja, haben wir gemacht. Wir haben eine Pülle Shampoos aufgemacht.
Auch weil wir dachten, wir hätten jetzt was Neues entdeckt, also eine Wasseratmosphäre auf dem Mond.
Wir haben auch den Mond beobachtet und das ist also sehr umstritten.
Gibt es Wasser auf dem Mond oder gibt es auch eine dünne Mondatmosphäre?
Und das hatten wir vorher gemutmaßt und wollten auch ganz speziell diese Atmosphäre suchen.
Leider konnten wir dann die Beobachtungsmodi, die wir ursprünglich durchführen
konnten, dann doch nicht durchführen.
Das war kurzfristig im März dann geändert worden, um die ganze Prozedur des
Mondvorbeiflugs nicht zu sehr zu verkomplizieren.
Und wir haben dann eine relativ einfache Messung gemacht, haben dann aber tatsächlich
so eine Wasseratmosphäre gesehen, wie auch vermutet.
Und dann stellte sich, wir waren dann ganz happy und dann haben wir auch tatsächlich
eine Flasche Champagner aufgemacht.
Und ja, wir haben also einmal einfach das Spacecraft,
der Satellit hat das sogenannte inertiale Pointing gemacht, das heißt das Ding
ist so am Mond vorbeigeflogen,
als wenn es den Mond nicht gäbe, das heißt hat das Pointing auf dem Mond mit
der Nadi-Plattform nicht geändert, sondern einfach so am Mond vorbeigeflogen
und man kriegte dann, was man da angeboten bekam.
Und nachdem wir vorbeigeflogen waren, das dauert dann drei, vier Kilometer pro
Sekunde, dann kann man sich ausrechnen, Monddurchmesser bei 3500,
dann ist man so nach 1000 Sekunden vorbei und dann haben wir,
wir haben ja ein Teleskop, was wir bewegen können,
dann haben wir wieder Richtung Mond geschaut, nachdem wir vorbeigeflogen sind
und haben diese Linien auch wieder gesehen, Wasserdampf.
Und ja, da waren wir also ganz froh. Tatsächlich, der Mond hat eine Wasserdampfatmosphäre
und das war was ganz Besonderes, weil das schon eben sehr lange gesucht wird
und bisher nie gefunden werden konnte.
Und wir haben nun in so einem Instrument eine extrem hohe Empfindlichkeit und
wir dachten, wir hätten es jetzt gefunden. Das Einzige, was da nicht passte,
war die Dopplerverschiebung.
Also wenn man mit sehr, sehr hoher Auflösung misst, kann man gleichzeitig auch
die Geschwindigkeit, mit der sich so ein Molekülverband bewegt,
also Wind als Beispiel, genau bestimmen. So ähnlich wie ein Radar.
Aber in diesem Fall ist es einfach die Dopplerverschiebung, ähnlich wie man
das halt vom Krankenwagen usw. her kennt.
Und die hätte eigentlich recht unterschiedlich sein müssen zwischen diesen beiden Beobachtungen.
Also einmal steil nach unten im Winkel von 90 Grad und einmal dann,
nachdem wir am Mond vorbeigeflogen sind, wieder auf den Mond geguckt,
in einem Winkel von 50 Grad und das war aber gleiche Dopplerverschiebung.
Und ja, nach einigem hin und her überlegen, kamen wir dann darauf,
wenn die Dopplerverschiebung sich nicht ändert, egal wie wir auf diese Atmosphäre
schauen, kann das nur bedeuten, dass es eigentlich eine Atmosphäre ist,
die der Satellit mit sich herum trägt.
Also wir sehen hier eine Wasseratmosphäre um den Satelliten herum.
Ah, okay.
Da war der Schampus aber schon offen.
Ja, der war schon weg und das haben wir erst eine Woche später gemerkt,
weil diese Auswertungen, die sind dann auch mal sehr aufwendig und die ursprüngliche
Begeisterung war dann natürlich ein bisschen verflogen,
andererseits natürlich auch ein sehr interessantes Ergebnis und zumal dann irgendwann
ein Vorbeiflugreport von der ESA veröffentlicht wurde von Angela Dietz und da stand dann drin,
dass man genau zu der Zeit, als wir dann tatsächlich diese Wasseratmosphäre entdeckt hatten,
Da die Bahn des Satelliten etwas verändert wurde und die wahrscheinlichste Erklärung
dafür ist, dass es zu irgendeinem Ausgasen von irgendwelchen Molekülen gekommen ist,
die dann den Satelliten in eine etwas andere Richtung gedreht haben.
Ausgasen jetzt aus dem Satellit heraus? ausgasen oder wo rausgasst sich da was aus?
Ja, also man hat ja den Start gehabt, der an Französisch-Goyana,
das ist ja feucht am Äquator, ich weiß nicht, ich war dabei und es hat geregnet,
es gab Donner und Blitz die ganze Zeit.
Mit einer Ariane 5 gestartet.
Ariane 5, genau und es ist so,
dass eine Seite des Satelliten bisher wohl immer nur kalt gewesen ist und,
in diesem Falle war es aber so, dass der Mond selber, der Mond ist ja relativ
dunkel, hat eine Albedo von, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, aber muss ich jetzt überlegen,
also irgendwas war es mit 0,253, ich will jetzt nichts Falsches sagen.
Auf jeden Fall, weil der Mond so dunkel ist, absorbiert er das Sonnenlicht viel
besser als die Erde und hat deswegen eine Oberflächentemperatur von bis zu 400
Grad Kelvin, also 130 Grad Celsius.
Und wenn der Satellit jetzt sehr nah am Mond vorbeifliegt und dann auf der sonnenbeschiedenen
Seite sich befindet, dann,
ist dann natürlich in einer sehr hohen Infrarotstrahlung des Mondes,
aus Wärmestrahlung des Mondes sozusagen ausgesetzt.
Und das hat dazu geführt, dass eine Seite des Satelliten, die bisher immer kalt
war, auch nach dem Start, warm geworden ist und dann angefangen hat auszugasen.
Und die Feuchtigkeit, die jetzt schon fast ein Jahr von dem Satelliten durchs
Weltall getragen wurde, ist dann in dem Moment einfach losgepufft.
Genau, genau.
Und dann schlugen sofort die Instrumente an.
Ja, und dann, wir hatten so ein schönes Video gemacht, wo man dann sehen konnte,
wo sozusagen der Beam des Instrumentes über die Oberfläche so am Äquator entlang geflogen ist.
Und dann konnte man sehen, ja, ja, hier in dem Mare so und so geht das dann los.
Und am Ende dieses Mares wird es dann wieder weniger.
Aber es stellt sich nachher heraus, das war nichts weiter als eben die Variabilität
des Ausgasens des Satelliten.
Und ich war dann letzte Woche in Berlin auf der EPSC, also European Planetary Science Kongresse.
Und da wurde ich dann auch von anderen Kollegen, die auch Instrumente auf Tuts
haben, angesprochen und.
Ich sprach dann auch ganz begeistert von unserem Press Release,
was wir gerade hatten auf der ESA-Webseite und auch auf der Webseite unseres Instituts,
wo wir dann so viele Spektrallinien in der Erde gesehen hatten und er meinte
dann, ich bin nicht interessiert an der Erde, die Erde ist ein sterbender Planet,
also ich bin nur interessiert am Mond und was wir da gesehen haben und dann
dachte ich mir schon, aha, er hat also auch irgendwas gesehen.
Und er hatte so einen Massenspektrometer und wollte aber nicht so richtig rausrücken,
weil das auch natürlich top secret, also wenn das wirklich echt gewesen wäre,
über die Mondatmosphäre und so weiter, top secret Informationen waren.
Und ich habe ihm dann gesagt, ja, ich glaube allerdings, also seit gestern sind
wir so der Meinung, dass wir tatsächlich gar nicht die Mondatmosphäre sehen,
sondern die Satellitenatmosphäre.
Und gestern hatten wir dann so eine Art Briefing, was Lega anging mit der ESA.
Da stellte sich heraus, dass auch noch mindestens ein, vielleicht zwei andere
Instrumente gedacht haben, sie hätten was besonders auf dem Mond gesehen.
Nachdem ich dann eindeutig sagen konnte, nee, nee, nee, das ist tatsächlich
ausgereisendes Satelliten, waren alle sehr enttäuscht.
Aber immerhin, man hat die Empfindlichkeit, also wir haben mal so ausgerechnet,
dass in dieser ganzen Phase des Mondvorbeiflugs, sagen wir, in einer halben
Stunde bis einer Stunde,
der wir also was gesehen haben, vielleicht ein Gramm Wasser,
Eis verdampft ist, sublimiert ist.
Also auf jeden Fall kann man sagen, das Instrument funktioniert gut und ist in der Lage,
so feine Dinge zu erkennen wie das eigene Halo, was durch so eine kurzfristige
Auserhitzung quasi durch den Mond,
ist ja auch irre, also da fliegt man also wirklich, dann kommt man da so aus
der Kälte, kommt am Mond vorbei und der Mond, so im Begriff eigentlich auch so des Nichts,
tostet einen dann erstmal so ein bisschen auf.
Und das ist natürlich an sich auch ein sehr interessantes Experiment,
so eine Art Grundlagenforschung,
weil man tatsächlich, man kann dann anhand der Spektrallinienbreite die Temperatur
des Wasserdampfs zum Beispiel messen.
Und man kann dann, wenn man in verschiedene Richtungen guckt,
hat man gesehen, ah die Temperatur hat sich geändert so ein bisschen und dann
ist die Atmosphäre wiederum so dünn, dass man zum Teil gar keine Stöße der Wassermoleküle hat,
wie man das normalerweise in der Atmosphäre hat, sagen wir mal oberhalb von einem Mikrobar.
Stöße?
Ja, normalerweise die Moleküle stoßen, hier in diesem Raum zum Beispiel stoßen die Moleküle,
ich weiß jetzt nicht so in der Größenordnung, 10 hoch 11, 10 hoch 12 mal pro
Sekunde, Das heißt, die mittlere freie Weglänge von so einem Luftmolekül ist
so im Nanometer oder Bruchteil eines Nanometers, bevor es sich dann wieder stößt.
Was dann dazu führt, dass man eine gewisse Energieverteilung der einzelnen Moleküle
der kinetischen Energie hat.
Und was dazu führt, dass man ein sogenanntes thermodynamisches Gleichgewicht hat.
Das heißt, alle Moleküle in diesem Raum, die fliegen so mit etwa 550 Meter pro
Sekunde, schätze ich mal, jetzt bei 20 Grad, 22 Grad Celsius,
führt dazu, dass sie eben so oft stoßen, dass egal wie schwer das Molekül ist,
alle einfach die gleiche Geschwindigkeit haben.
Egal ob Wasserstoff oder Sauerstoff oder vielleicht ein Edelgas, was sehr schwer ist.
Die haben alle die gleiche Geschwindigkeit. Während wenn ich jetzt in die obere
Atmosphäre gehe, oberhalb von 100 Kilometern Höhe, fangen die sich an zu trennen,
diese verschiedenen Moleküle, weil die halt nicht mehr so häufig stoßen.
Und ich kriege dann verschiedene Atmosphären sozusagen. Und beim Satelliten
ist es so, dass eben die Stöße möglicherweise eben so selten sind,
dass die Temperaturen auch völlig anders definiert sind.
Also man definiert ja eine Temperatur über die Geschwindigkeit der einzelnen
Moleküle und die Energie dieser einzelnen Moleküle.
Und da oben in den sehr dünnen Atmosphären ist das nicht so einfach.
Da kann das sein, dass ich eine Temperatur in x-Richtung habe, eine in y und eine in z.
Je nachdem, ob die Moleküle stoßen oder ob die nur in eine Richtung stoßen oder
in alle anderen Richtungen.
Und das ist eigentlich eine Sache, die man im Labor relativ schwer simulieren
kann, weil man ja ein paar hundert Kilometer freies Volumen darum braucht,
weil die Moleküle die Gasen dann aus mit ein paar hundert Metern pro Sekunde
oder Kilometer pro Sekunde,
und von daher hoffen wir, dass wir sozusagen dann bei noch detaillierterer Analyse
der Spektren vielleicht ein bisschen mehr über diese Ausgasvorgänge und die
Stoßvorgänge der Wassermoleküle lernen können.
Von daher ist es an sich eigentlich ein sehr interessantes Experiment gewesen.
Mit anderen Worten, Druze funktioniert zumindest, was das SWI-Instrument betrifft,
kann man schon mal festhalten.
Jetzt steht noch eine Reise an. Wir haben es schon angedeutet,
29 ist Ankunft oder geht es dann erst richtig los zum Jupiter und dann nochmal zwei Jahre?
Also wann ist die Ankunft am Jupiter? 29 oder 31?
31, Sommer 31.
Okay, also müssen wir noch ein bisschen warten, sieben Jahre,
bis es dann so richtig interessant wird.
Schauen wir doch mal so ein bisschen auf die Erkundung des Jupiters,
so wie sie denn bisher so gelaufen ist, weil das ist ja jetzt nicht der erste
Besuch, den die Menschheit dem Jupiter dann abstatten wird, sondern es gab ja
schon das eine oder andere,
was dort vorbeigeflogen ist, auch wenn das eigentliche Ziel nicht der Jupiter war.
Da gehören, glaube ich, diese Pioneer-Sonden dazu, Voyager natürlich,
die ja alles abgeklappert haben und auch immer noch abklappern,
wenn die Planeten mittlerweile schon weit zurückliegen.
Die erste dedizierte Jupiter-Mission war dann Galileo.
Galileo ist glaube ich 1994 dort beim Jupiter angekommen und hat sich da relativ
lang getummelt, neun Jahre lang alles erforscht.
Und inwiefern, das wirst du ja auch aktiv quasi begleitet haben, diesen Vorgang.
Was war denn so der Erkenntnisgewinn in der Zeit, immer wenn so eine Sonde so
einen Ort erreicht, wo man eigentlich so noch nie war.
Und bis dahin ist ja quasi alles, was man wusste, ist, was man von der Erde
aussehen kann, was man von den Weltraumteleskopen um die Erde herum sehen konnte
und was man bei den Vorbeiflügen kam und was man sich vielleicht ausgerechnet hat.
Was hat dann die Galileo-Mission an neuen Erkenntnissen geliefert?
Ja, ich muss sagen, zur damaligen Zeit, 1994, habe ich mich mit Jupiter noch
nicht so intensiv beschäftigt.
Aber von dem, was ich so sagen kann, hat man natürlich schöne Bilder von den Monden gekriegt.
Man hat Ringe entdeckt, dünne Ringe des Jupiters.
Man hat die Magnetosphäre intensiv untersucht. Man hat gelernt,
dass Io eben vulkanisch aktiv ist und permanent ungefähr eine Tonne Material,
also hauptsächlich Schwefelverbindungen, ausstößt, die das schwere Feld des
Io verlassen und dann durch die Sonnenstrahlung ionisiert werden.
Und diese elektrisch geladenden Teilchen wiederum, also Protonen oder eben Atome,
Moleküle und Elektronen dann entlang der Magnetfeldlinien, des sehr starken
Magnetfelds des Jupiters, gürieren und sehr, sehr hohe Geschwindigkeiten erreichen,
dass also die Strahlung im inneren Jupitersystem extrem hoch ist,
also Teilchenstrahlung, die dann Gammastrahlung erzeugt.
Und ja, was kann ich sonst sagen? Das ist jetzt so, was mir gerade so einfällt.
Interessant war auch übrigens bei Galileo, dass Galileo auch einen Erdvorbeiflug
hatte und damals dieser Carl Sagan die Idee hatte, anhand der Messdaten der
Instrumente auf Galileo festzustellen, ob die Erde bewohnbar ist und ob tatsächlich
Leben existiert. Aber das nur so ganz nebenbei.
Das haben wir jetzt auch versucht beim Jupiter-Verbeiflug.
Also die sogenannten Nicht-Gleichgewichts-Chemie als Beispiel,
wenn ich eine Sauerstoffatmosphäre habe wie auf der Erde und messe viel Methan,
dann deutet das darauf hin, dass dort viel Methan permanent erzeugt wird.
Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es durch biologische Aktivität erzeugt, ist eben sehr hoch.
Oder wenn ich flüssiges Wasser habe, also Ozeane, was man halt auch mit Galileo
feststellen konnte. Aber zurück zum Jupiter.
Man hat eben sehr viele neue Erkenntnisse im Vergleich zu den Vorbeiflugsonden damals gewonnen.
Man wollte auch mit der Galileo Probe in die tiefere Atmosphäre eindringen.
Da hat man aber angeblich einen sogenannten Hotspot erwischt. Und man hatte gehofft,
dass man Wasserwolken findet oder dass man halt mehr sagen kann über tatsächlich
die Verteilung von Wasserdampfer. Da hat man nichts gefunden.
Das war also sehr, sehr trocken, was eigentlich damals eine ungewöhnliche Erkenntnis war.
Und man hat die Desphäre versucht zu kompensieren mit der Juno-Mission,
die jetzt immer noch aktiv ist.
Ich kann mich ja noch erinnern, ich meine man wird ja auch so groß mit so einem
gewissen Weltbild oder vielmehr mit einem gewissen Weltallbild.
Am Anfang war Pluto noch ein Planet und andere Dinge ändern sich auch.
Und was vor allem sich permanent geändert hat, das war immer so der Mondcount von Jupiter und Saturn.
Also ich glaube, ich bin mal, als ich so in die Welt kam, hatte der Jupiter,
weiß ich nicht mehr, irgendeine einstellige Zahl an Monden offiziell oder zwölf
maximal auf jeden Fall nicht so viele, wie man heute weiß.
Ich glaube, der aktuelle Stand ist 79.
Ich glaube mehr als 100.
Mehr als 100?
Ja, ich musste mal einen Vortrag halten im Rahmen einer Lehrerfortbildung.
Und da habe ich angefangen mit meinem alten Was-ist-was-Buch,
das ich 1967 geschenkt bekommen habe und 1963 rauskam.
Und damals waren es zwölf. Und dann gab es ein Buch, das hatte mein Sohn aus dem Jahr 2001.
Da waren es dann schon über 50. Und wenn man jetzt bei Wikipedia nachguckt,
kommt man wahrscheinlich auch über 100.
Wikipedia sagt 95.
Ja, gut.
Stand Juni 23.
Ja gut, das heißt jetzt sind wir September 24.
Entdeckt worden sein. Aber Galileo, die Mission hieß ja nicht ohne Grund so,
sondern es war die Beobachtung von Galileo Galilei.
Man spricht halt von den galiläischen Monden, Io, Europa, Ganymed und Callisto.
Das sind die größten Monde und vielleicht auch erstmal so die interessantesten,
weil was größer ist, ist immer interessant.
Die hat sich dann, die Sonde Galileo auch genauer angeschaut, nehme ich an.
Sicherlich, ja. Und es gibt eben Hinweise darauf, dass diese Monde eben außer
Io auch über einen Ozean verfügen unter der Oberfläche.
Bei Europa hat man das ja schon relativ früh vermutet, einfach anhand der Oberflächenstruktur.
Das sieht ja so ein bisschen aus wie sich bewegende Platten.
Und ja, möglicherweise beginnt dieser Ozean schon 10 Kilometer unterhalb der Oberfläche.
Bei Ganymed vermutet man auch einen solchen, aber eher so in 150 Kilometer Tiefe und ja,
einen relativ dünnen, wenn man so will, was die vertikale Ausdehnung angeht.
Ozean vermutet man auch bei Callisto.
Das ist zum Beispiel eine interessante Erkenntnis und das ist eben auch eine
der großen Fragen, stimmt das wirklich jetzt?
Das hat man teilweise anhand von Gravitationsanomalien feststellen können oder
anhand von Beeinflussungen des externen Magnetfeldes durch möglicherweise Ströme
in diesen salzwasserartigen Gebilden, die halt eine hohe Leitfähigkeit dann haben.
Und ja, das ist eben auch eine der großen Fragestellungen, die wir jetzt bei Juice haben.
Gibt es da Ozeane, in welcher Tiefe sind sie? Wie sind sie ausgedehnt etc.?
Da würde ich gerne nochmal drauf eingehen. Weil, was heißt denn das?
Man vermutet, dass da ein Ozean in 150 Kilometer, ich meine das ist ja extrem
speziell und ich meine 150 Kilometer haben wir ja auf der Erde noch nicht mal gegraben bekommen.
Woraus zieht man solche Schlüsse? Also was, mal abgesehen jetzt von,
das sieht mir nach Ozean aus, wenn ich drauf schaue, was sind sozusagen die
Messmethoden, die jetzt hier primär Daten liefern, aus denen man dann ableiten
kann, da muss ein Ozean sein.
Also wir reden ja von Wasser, also ein Wasserozean.
Ja, das ist zum einen, wie sozusagen der Mond rotiert um seine eigene Achse
und wie dann eine Flüssigkeit oder ein Ozean dieselbe beeinflusst.
Und zum anderen eben, wie die elektrischen Eigenschaften eines solchen Leiters,
Salzwasser leitet ja sehr gut, dann die Magnetfelder und elektrischen Felder,
die man um den Mond herum misst,
die natürlichen Felder beeinflussen. Das sind so die Hauptmethoden.
Und da ist man sich dann so sicher? oder man...
Man hat halt Fehlerbalken, natürlich, das sind so Abschätzungen.
Das ist ja immer so eine Art Fernerkundung und Fernerkundung ist ja kein direktes
Messen, man misst die elektromagnetischen Wellen meinetwegen oder man misst,
die physikalischen Parameter, aber die Schlussfolgerung ist immer eine Abschätzung.
Also eine Messung ist nur, wenn ich einen Thermometer nehme,
manche in Quecksilber und direkt jetzt in die Erde stecke oder ins Wasser,
das ist eine direkte Messung, aber wenn ich zum Beispiel vom Satelliten aus
mit dem Infrarotspektrometer,
die die emission von der oberfläche messe ist das immer eine
abschätzung weil ich messe die elektromagnetische strahlung muss die interpretieren
mit einem modell und so ist es in diesem fall auch ich habe als ein modell und
das modell sagt mir ja es am wahrscheinlichsten dass ich bei europa halten ozean
habt ja schon in zehn kilometer tiefe beginnt während bei ganymed muss der viel
tiefer unten stehen so muss man sich das vorstellen okay.
So, der Jupiter und ich weiß nicht, wie viele von diesen Monden muss man denn
sonst noch jetzt sozusagen als relevant für die Erforschung heranziehen,
abgesehen von den vier dicken Teilen, die man von hier aus sieht mit dem Fernrohr?
Für die Juice Mission sind eigentlich nur diese vier oder eigentlich sogar nur
drei relevant, weil es da Vorbeiflüge gibt.
Aber das kommt natürlich darauf an, wen man da jetzt fragt. Die Frage ist, wo kommen die Monde her?
Wie sehen sie aus? Wie ist die Oberflächenstruktur? Wie ist die Helligkeit der
Oberfläche, die Albedo, die Reflektivität?
Wie ist sie zusammengesetzt?
Ist dort Material an der Oberfläche, die vielleicht von anderen Monden herrühren?
Man kennt ja das Beispiel Enceladus auf Saturn-System.
Der mit den Wasserfontänen.
Genau, genau. Und hier haben wir eben tatsächlich Io. Das Io spuckt sozusagen
Material in das Jupiter-System.
Und da ist dann zum Beispiel die Frage, wie verteilt sich das und kann die Spuren
davon auf diesen Körpern sehen.
Und ja, in diesem Sinne gibt es da natürlich unzählige Fragestellungen,
je nachdem, wie man da fragt und wer sich da jetzt mit auskennt.
Ich kenne mich wie gesagt mehr mit Atmosphären aus, ein bisschen mit Oberflächen,
aber das sind so die Hauptfragen.
Man kennt ja Beispiele, dass die Albedo eines Mondes an zwei verschiedenen Seiten
sehr unterschiedlich ist,
weil er sozusagen entlang seiner Bahn Material aufsammelt und dann sozusagen
im Lee eher weniger Material aufsammelt und so weiter.
Und das sind dann so die indirekte Hinweise auf die Verteilung von Staub zum
Beispiel im entsprechenden System.
Galileo hat ja jetzt auch nochmal so einen besonderen Moment mit messen dürfen,
nämlich den Einschlag des Schumacher Levi 9,
der halt zufällig mehr oder weniger seine Laufbahn im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
am Jupiter beendet hat und in die Jupiter-Atmosphäre reingestürzt ist.
Ich glaube, man hat zwar eigentlich Glück, aber dann doch wieder ein bisschen
Pech gehabt, weil wäre man ein bisschen früher gekommen, hätte man es noch genauer messen können.
Aber da kam, glaube ich, die Challenger-Katastrophe dazwischen,
die zu einem verspäteten Start geführt hat von Galileo.
Solche Ereignisse sind ja nun wirklich super selten, oder? Dass man da auch noch in der Nähe ist.
Ja, ob die so selten sind, ist natürlich die Frage.
Ich meine, möglicherweise gibt es öfter mal so Kometeneinschläge in die Gasriesen,
aber man sieht sie denn halt nicht.
Ja, trotzdem, man hat ja recht gute Bilder, sowohl im optischen als auch im Infraroten.
Man sieht also, dass der Komet, bevor er eingeschlagen ist, auseinandergebrochen
ist und ich glaube, ich weiß nicht,
irgendwie im 44 Grad Süd, ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher,
weil es irgendwie in die südliche Halbkugel eingeschlagen ist und man sieht
zum Teil, dass dann Material aus der unteren Atmosphäre nach oben transportiert wurde,
also die Farbe sozusagen der Atmosphäre sich geändert hat und gleichzeitig an
den Einstiegstellen die Infrarotstrahlung stark anstieg, das heißt es war sehr heiß.
Und man weiß halt auch dann eben aus Messungen im Millimeter- und Submillimeterwellenbereich
unter anderem, dass dort Material eingetragen wurde, zum Beispiel Kohlenmonoxid, Wasserdampf.
HCl, CS. und dass dieses Material dann in der mittleren Atmosphäre hängen geblieben ist.
Also so irgendwo im Bereich von einigen hundert Millibar bis vielleicht einigen
paar Millibar sich dann über diese mittleren Atmosphäre verteilt hat,
sowohl in der Höhe als auch in der Horizontalen, also Ost, West, Nord, Süd.
Also insgesamt kann man sagen, dass diese Atmosphäre von Jupiter sehr wenig
Sauerstoff enthält und durch diesen Einschlag Sauerstoff in die Atmosphäre eingetragen
wurde, was dann zu bestimmten chemischen Reaktionen führt, die ganz interessant sind.
Aber in diesem Zusammenhang ist es eben interessant, dass der Wasserdampf sich
im Laufe der Zeit sehr langsam nur ausgebreitet hat.
Das heißt, das sieht fast so aus, als wenn die sogenannte meridionale Zirkulation,
das heißt der Transport von Pol zu Pol eben sehr, sehr langsam geht auf Jupiter.
Also das heißt, der Einschlag, wann war das? 94 oder so.
Und wir haben mal Messungen gemacht mit dem Hershel Space Observatory, ich glaube in 2011,
also fast 30 Jahre später und da konnte man sehen, dass dieser vom Kometen eingetragene
Wasserdampf immer noch mehr oder weniger in der südlichen Hemisphäre war.
Also ein bisschen über den Äquator
rübergewandert, aber vielleicht bis 10 Grad Nord oder 20 Grad Nord,
aber ja, das fand ich war eine interessante Erkenntnis, dass man sozusagen diese.
Eingetragenen Gase als Tracer für die Zirkulation verwenden konnte von daher
interessante Geschichte, eine andere interessante Geschichte wäre,
das konnte man bisher nicht messen, wie ist eigentlich die isotopische Zusammensetzung
des Wassers, was da eingetragen wurde,
man hat so zwei Typen von Kometen, bei denen man das bisher analysiert hat,
sogenannte Rodcloud Also Kometen der Ortschen Wolke und Kometen der Jupiter-Familie.
Also die Ortsche Wolke, das war so richtig, richtig, richtig weit gelassen ist.
Genau, richtig, richtig, genau. Und die Kometen der Ortschen Wolke kommen relativ
selten dann ins Innere-Sonnensystem, während diejenigen der Jupiter-Familie
halt Orbits von, was weiß ich, 5 bis 20 Jahren haben und öfter mal auch an der
Erde oder eben relativ nah an der Sonne vorbeiziehen.
Und die unterscheiden sich, was man bisher so weiß, wobei das auch kontrovers
diskutiert wird, weil die Interpretation der Messungen oder die Auswertung der
Messungen ein großes Thema sind,
unterscheiden sich aber im Isotopenverhältnis vom Wasser, also zum Beispiel dem d zu h Verhältnis.
Und nun wäre es mal interessant zu erfahren, wie ist eigentlich das Isotopenverhältnis
des Wassers in der Jupiter-Stratosphäre?
Das konnte man bisher halt noch nicht messen. Also das heißt,
mit anderen Worten, sehe ich da sozusagen ein Abbild dessen,
was ich bisher so in Kometen gemessen habe?
Oder sehe ich möglicherweise viel, viel niedrigere Deuterium-Werte,
so wie sie im Wasserstoff vorhanden sind?
Also die Jupiter-Atmosphäre besteht zum großen Teil aus Wasserstoff,
also Moleklar und Wasserstoff H2 und es gibt dann ungefähr mit einem 500.000 Anteil HD,
also anstatt H2 HD, D ist Neuterium, also da wird das Proton durch einen Proton und Neutron ersetzt.
Und ja, ist es jetzt in den letzten 30 Jahren oder 40 Jahren ja mittlerweile
zu einem Austausch, nee 30 Jahre,
zu einem Austausch der Isotope des Wasserstoffs mit dem des Wassers gekommen, also des Deuteriums.
Und das ist zum Beispiel eine interessante Frage.
Ist es möglich, über diesen Zeitplan tatsächlich eine sogenannte Äquilibrierung
des Wassers mit dem umgebenden Wasserstoff herzustellen oder nicht?
Oder habe ich nach wie vor den relativ hohen Wert, den ich von einem Kometen
erwarte? Also es ist so, dass Kometen, die hauptsächlich aus Eis bestehen,
dass die von Haus aus eher viel höhere D-zu-H-Verhältnisse aufweisen als zum Beispiel Wasserstoff.
Und das hat einfach mit der Entstehung des Wassers zu tun im interstellaren Medium.
Also man kann quasi daran, man kann die Art des Wassers interpretieren und daraus
eine Schlussfolgerung vielleicht ableiten mit wo kommt es her?
Ja, unter anderem, wo kommt es her, aber eben interessant ist,
diesen Bereich, also man hat bisher einen Bereich von vielleicht 1,4 bis vielleicht
5 oder 6 mal 10 und minus 4.
An D zu H-Fällen ist im Wasser bisher gemessen und die Frage ist,
ist das jetzt ein Wert, der da in diesem Bereich liegt oder ist er möglicherweise
viel höher oder viel niedriger?
Wahrscheinlich ist er niedriger, aber jedenfalls mit unserem Instrument werden
wir in der Lage sein, das eben mit sehr hoher Genauigkeit messen zu können.
Das ist unter anderem auch eine Motivation, sozusagen das vom Kometen eigentragende
Wasser genauer zu analysieren. Es geht nicht nur um Doterium,
aber auch um die Sauerstoffisotope 17 und 18.
Da sind wir sehr gespannt drauf. Insgesamt ist es übrigens so, dass man,
obwohl es in der oberen Troposphäre, also vielleicht bis 10 Bar,
relativ viel Wasser in der Jupiter-Atmosphäre geben soll, also relativ,
absolut gesehen natürlich nicht,
wird dieses aber nicht in die mittlere Atmosphäre eingetragen,
weil die obere Troposphäre, die Tropopause sehr, sehr kalt ist und da sozusagen
alles an Wasserdampf ausfriert.
Und deswegen habe ich praktisch keinen Austausch zwischen der unteren Atmosphäre
und der mittleren Atmosphäre.
Ähnliches Phänomen wie in der Erdatmosphäre. Dort wird Wasserdampf hauptsächlich
am Äquator durch diese Cumulonimbus-Wolken, also diese sehr hoch aufsteigenden
Wolken in die Mittelatmosphäre eingetragen,
weil auch hier in der Erdatmosphäre eben die Troposphäre relativ kalt ist und
der Dampfdruck des Wassers dort
entsprechend so gering ist, dass nur sehr geringe Mengen vorhanden sind.
Also ich merke schon mal, ich spüre richtig den Blick des Atmosphärenforschers
auf den Planeten, aber tatsächlich ist das ja auch etwas, was sehr viel des
Wesens dieses Planetens ausmacht.
Ich meine, man hat so den Kern, keine Ahnung, gibt es eine Annahme darüber,
was im Kern des Jupiter so vorliegt?
Ja, es gibt verschiedene Theorien, aber grundsätzlich kann man davon ausgehen,
es gibt irgendeinen festen Kern, der aus Silikaten und so weiter,
aus Gesteinen entsteht.
Dann hat man festen und dann flüssigen Wasserstoff und teilweise sogenannter
metallischer Wasserstoff und irgendwann weiter oben natürlich nur gasförmigen Wasserstoff.
Aber durch die hohen Drücke ist es eben so, dass die Aggregatzustände eben selbst
von Wasserstoff sich so ändern, dass man dort festen Wasserstoff hat als Festkörper.
Aber trotzdem ist es so, dass der innere Kern wahrscheinlich wie bei anderen
Planeten auch aus Material, was dort halt damals rumflog, sich entwickelt hat.
Auch Eisen?
Ja, kann man von ausgeben.
Kann man von ausgeben.
Ja, also eben alles, was damals halt so in der Protosolanwolke beziehungsweise
Protoplanetanscheibe vorhanden war.
Trotzdem ist ja unser Blick auf den Jupiter immer so ein bisschen geprägt von
Stürmen und das ist ja, sagen wir mal, so die populäre Wahrnehmung.
Also man hat da in der Horizontalen sehr viel Bewegung, wenn ich dich jetzt
richtig verstanden habe, waren die Erkenntnisse dieser Kometenbeobachtung über
einen längeren Zeitraum schon eher die,
dass von Pol zu Pol da gar nicht so viel passiert.
Also im Prinzip dreht sich alles im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes dort im Kreis,
aber das ist alles eine extrem horizontale Bewegung und auch in den Höhenschichten
der Atmosphäre gibt es relativ wenig Austausch.
Ja, also man muss hier unterscheiden zwischen eben dem, was man so sieht im optischen Bereich,
also diese Wolken, diese Bells and Stripes, da vermutet man ja,
dass so eher durch hellen Materialien auch aufsteigende Gase sind und die dunkleren abfallende,
also durch das Aufsteigen habe ich eine adiabatische Expansion und dementsprechende
Abkühlung und Kondensation der Gase und umgekehrt eine Sublimation beim Absteigen.
Und wichtig ist beim Jupiter halt auch, dass er sehr stark, also sehr schnell
rotiert und deswegen ich sehr kleine Wirbelstrukturen erzeugen kann.
Der sogenannte Rosspideformationsradius, was man auch sehr schön sieht auf den
Bildern der Juno-Sonde, die halt erstmalig über die Pole fliegt.
Und je weiter ich zu den Polen komme, desto interessantere Strukturen sehe ich
da, als wenn das gemalt wäre von irgendeinem Künstler.
Und ich sehe, dass die Wirbelstrukturen halt auch immer kleiner werden.
Deswegen ist es auch sehr schwierig, Jupiter zu modellieren,
so als Klimamodellierer,
weil das extrem hohe Auflösung in den allgemeinen Zirkulationsmodellen benötigt.
Aber was sozusagen relativ wenig erforscht ist, ist tatsächlich die Atmosphäre
in dem Bereich, wo ich nichts sehe, weil ich halt dort keine Wolken habe.
Das ist eben die mittlere Atmosphäre.
Da sieht man ein bisschen was, man sieht da zum Teil Aerosole,
aber man sieht halt keine Wolken.
Also warum sieht man nichts?
Ja, weil einfach keine Wolken da sind, weil die Zusammensetzung dieses Bereichs
halt ein anderer ist und eben Wolkenbildung nicht möglich ist.
Also man sieht nichts im optischen Bereich.
Man sieht eben tatsächlich nur was in einem Bereich, in dem man sozusagen wiederum
die Moleküle anschauen kann.
Wie gesagt, man kann sich ja abschätzen, wie hoch die Windgeschwindigkeiten
zum Beispiel in der oberen Troposphäre sind, wo man halt den großen roten Fleck
sieht oder wo man halt die gegengläufigen Wolkensysteme sieht.
Das kann man dann ja so abschätzen, aber in der Mittelatmosphäre hat man halt
diese optischen Hinweise nicht und deswegen weiß man relativ wenig über diesen Bereich.
Man weiß also nicht, wie zum Beispiel der Impuls und Energietransport von der
oberen Atmosphäre in die oberen Atmosphäre geschieht.
In der oberen Atmosphäre hat man nicht so richtig verstanden,
warum die obere Atmosphäre, die Thermosphäre so heiß ist.
Der Prozess ist nicht so gut verstanden. Und eine Möglichkeit wäre zum Beispiel
Wellentransport aus der unteren Atmosphäre durch die mittlere Atmosphäre in
die Thermosphäre, wo die Wellen dann sozusagen disziplieren würden und auch
Impuls übertragen würden. Aber das sind alles wiederum nur Theorien.
Disziplieren heißt was?
Dissipieren heißt, dass praktisch die Wellenenergie in Wärme umgewandelt wird, als Beispiel.
Weil Wellen übertragen ja immer Energie und Impuls. Und deswegen,
also Galileo und auch Juno sind eigentlich Missionen, die tatsächlich,
was die Atmosphärenforschung angeht,
mehr fokussiert waren auf die Unteratmosphäre.
Juno hat versucht bis 100 Bar oder vielleicht sogar bis 1000 Bar Messungen durchzuführen.
Während die DUS-Mission eher so den oberen Teil der Atmosphäre sich anschaut.
Also obere Troposphäre bis Thermosphäre und dann natürlich weiter die Magnetosphäre.
Aber wenn wir jetzt von der eigentlichen neutralen Atmosphäre sprechen,
kann man eben sagen Stratosphäre und Thermosphäre.
Juno hatten wir noch gar nicht erwähnt. Also Galileo ist eine abgeschlossene
Mission, das ist vorbei.
Juno ist 2016 am Jupiter aufgetaucht und ist immer noch aktiv. und macht Dinge.
Das ist eine NASA-Mission, die...
Ganz erfolgreich ist, kann man sagen?
Ja, kann man sagen, würde ich sagen. Hat viele neuartige Messungen durchgeführt,
zum Beispiel durch das Instrument MWR, Mikrowellenradiometer,
das eben zum Beispiel in die sehr tiefe Atmosphäre reinblicken kann oder jetzt
auch Oberflächenmessungen auf den Galileischen Mohnen gemacht haben.
Sehr interessante Messungen, die erst teilweise publiziert wurden für Ganymed
hauptsächlich, Europa und Io noch nicht.
Da gab es also Überflüge. Und man hat dann gesehen, dass bei den größeren Wellenlängen
die Temperatur stark ansteigt.
Also je größer die Wellenlänge ist, desto tiefer kann man in das Eis hineinschauen.
Und da sieht man das eben bei den großen Wellenlängen. Große Wellenlänge ist
ungefähr ein halber Meter Wellenlänge, dass man dort einen sehr starken Anstieg
der Temperaturen sieht im Vergleich zur Oberfläche.
Und ja, das ist eine relativ komplexe Auswertung. Man hat auch da Wechselwirkungen
mit der sogenannten Synchrotonstrahlung des Jupiters.
Und das führt aber dazu, dass man mehr und mehr über die Struktur des Eises der Oberfläche lernt.
Und das ist jetzt gerade im Moment im Gange, dass dort diese Art von Daten ausgewertet werden.
Eben Ganymed ist glaube ich noch in der Mache und Europa, da ist noch nichts
publiziert worden. und neulich war halt Überflug von Io, ist wiederum völlig anders.
Damit wir uns jetzt vielleicht nicht in diesen Details zu sehr verlieren,
würde ich es gerne nochmal anders machen.
Angenommen wir wären jetzt quasi komplett temperaturresistent und ich könnte
jetzt einfach und auch druckresistent und überhaupt strahlenresistent,
also total resistent und ich falle jetzt quasi aus dem All auf den Jupiter.
Was wäre denn das und ich würde jetzt so quasi langsam dem, was auch immer der
Boden dort sein könnte, wenn es so einen Ort überhaupt gibt,
Was kann man jetzt aus dem, was man bisher meint zu wissen oder was man beobachtet
hat ablesen Also wann, was ist so das Erste, auf was ich treffe und wie geht
es dann weiter wenn ich so langsam einfach,
dem Zentrum mich nähere oder vielleicht schnell, weil das ist ja relativ groß.
Ja und hat eine entsprechend hohe Schwerkraft. Aber ob man so schnell fällt,
ist eben die Frage, weil natürlich die Dichte immer weiter zunimmt und deswegen irgendwann… Ja.
Okay, ignorieren wir das einfach mal. Ich bewege mich mit konstanter Geschwindigkeit
jetzt sozusagen auf den Jupiter zu.
Was spüre ich als erstes? Was ist sozusagen das Erste, was ich wahrnehme von dieser Atmosphäre?
Was bildet quasi die Außenhaut, das Erste, was nicht alles?
Ja, es kommt doch an, welcher Geschwindigkeit man da jetzt reinfällt.
Also wenn ich jetzt von oben steil, einfach nach unten runter plumpse.
Also man stellt sich vor, man ist da in irgendeinem...
Also ich reagiere gar nicht.
Ich schaue nur. Es kommt darauf an, ob man natürlich sozusagen in einem Orbit
und so weiter ist oder ob man da einfach steht und dann runterfällt,
das ist natürlich was ganz anderes.
Wenn ich da mit hoher Geschwindigkeit um Jupiter rumfliege, ist natürlich auch
selbst die sehr, sehr dünne Atmosphäre, kann schon eben zu hohen Reibungsverlusten
führen und entsprechenden Temperaturen.
Ich traue einfach nur ein. Dann habe ich eben erst eine Thermosphäre,
eine sehr hohe Temperatur.
Was heißt das, eine sehr hohe Temperatur?
Ja, da kommt man dann auf Werte von 600, vielleicht 1000 Grad.
Tatsächlich so heiß.
So ähnlich auch wie in der Erdmosphäre,
da habe ich ja auch sehr hohe Temperaturen in der Thermosphäre.
Aber wo kommen die her, diese Temperaturen?
Das weiß man eben nicht so genau bei Jupiter. Bei der Erde kommen die hauptsächlich
dadurch, dass eben sehr kurzfällige UV-Strahlung absorbiert wird.
Ähnlich wie mit der Ozonschicht weiter unten, wo die UV-Strahlung ein bisschen...
Also mehr eine Aufheizung durch andere Strahlung, die dort ankommt.
Und gleichzeitig hat man kein Molekül, das im Infrarotbereich abstrahlen kann.
So ist es auf der Erde zumindest. Und bei Mars hat man zum Beispiel CO2.
CO2 kann immer abstrahlen, deswegen
hat man dort keine sehr heiße Thermosphäre, auch wie bei der Venus.
Aber auf der Erde hat man das und auf Jupiter hat man das halt auch.
Wobei bei Jupiter versteht man das an sich nicht, weil der solare Fluss eigentlich nicht ausreicht.
Und da muss es halt noch irgendeine andere Quelle geben.
Aber man weiß, es ist so heiß außen. Ja, genau. Also ich hätte mir das Ganze
eher so als so eine eisige Umgebung vorgestellt, aber tatsächlich als erstes
würde ich erst mal getoastet werden, wenn ich nicht totally invincible wäre.
Ja, getoastet ist vielleicht zu viel gesagt. Die Atmosphäre ist ja sehr,
sehr dünn. Man merkt da nicht viel.
Ach so, es ist heiß und ich merke nichts davon?
Ja, weil einfach die ganze, ja, ich meine, ich spreche über Mikrobar bis Nanobar.
Das ist also Hochvakuum eigentlich.
Oder Hochvakuum vielleicht noch nicht, jedenfalls Vakuum. Das heißt,
wenn ich da jetzt, ich meine, wenn ich jetzt in Erd bin gegenüber Temperaturen
oder unabhängig von Temperaturen drücken und so weiter, passiert mir natürlich
nichts. Aber normalerweise als Mensch würden wir da natürlich sofort,
weil Vakuum ist, auseinanderfliegen.
Aber wenn man da halt die Temperaturen messen würde, würde man halt feststellen,
da geht es dann schon damit los, überhaupt zu schauen, welche Art von Temperatur messe ich da gerade.
Es gibt ja die Temperaturen, die Sie am Boden kennen, die charakterisiert sind
die Gase durch Maxwell-Boltzmann-Verteilung und dann gibt es halt die Gase in
sehr dünnen Atmosphären, wo dann die, wie ich anfangs schon sagte,
mit dem Spacecraft da vorhin,
dass die Moleküle in verschiedene Richtungen verschieden schnell fliegen können
und so weiter, wo ich also in dem Sinne verschiedene Temperaturen pro Richtung
habe oder pro Übergang des Moleküls, Rotationstemperaturen, Vibration und so
weiter und so fort. Das ist also ein Thema für die Wissenschaft für sich.
Man muss sich also jetzt nicht so eine Temperatur vorstellen,
wie jetzt hier, es ist heiß und es ist überall gleichmäßig diese Temperatur,
sondern diese Temperatur liegt in diesen Molekülen vor.
Ja, die kinetische Energie der einzelnen Moleküle, genau.
Weil die da einfach hoch angeregt sind und diese Energie in sich tragen,
aber es gibt so wenig davon, dass ich also nicht wirklich getoastet werde,
sondern es fliegen einfach nur so kleine 600 Grad heiße Moleküle durch mich durch.
Ja, so in der Art, durch mich durch vielleicht nicht, aber fliegen da halt…
Gegen mich gegen. Genau, genau.
Und dann geht es weiter runter in die Stratosphäre. Stratosphäre heißt ja,
das ist eine, das kommt vom Englischen Stratified,
also eben eine geschichtete atmosphärische Schicht oder Schale,
in der halt keine Konvektion stattfindet.
Das heißt so eine Art Inversionswetterlage im Winter, das heißt die Temperatur
nimmt nach oben hinzu anstatt ab.
Und in der Erde kommt das ja durch die Ozonschicht zustande,
die UV-Strahlung absorbiert und deswegen die Temperatur nach oben hin steigen lässt.
Also in 50 Kilometer Höhe habe ich ja eine ähnliche Temperatur wie am Boden.
Und bei Jupiter geschieht das durch Absorption der Sonnenstrahlung durch Aerosole und Methan.
Das heißt, ich habe dann nach oben hin, je weiter ich nach oben komme,
desto wärmer wird es. Und irgendwann in der unteren Stratosphäre wird es dann
entsprechend kälter, bis ich in die Troposphäre komme.
Aber ist es dann immer noch alles so vakuummäßig oder wird es jetzt schon so dicht?
Nein, da komme ich schon in den Bereich von, also obere Troposphäre komme ich
schon in den Bereich von, was weiß ich, Erdatmosphäre in 10 Kilometern Höhe oder so ähnlich.
Oder 20 Kilometern Höhe und dann komme ich halt in die Troposphäre und da wird
es dann wieder wärmer, wenn ich nach unten falle.
Und da entstehen dann Temperaturen, die gehen dann in die hunderte oder tausende
Grad, je weiter ich nach unten komme, desto wärmer wird es halt.
Tausend ist, also ich weiß jetzt gar nicht genau.
Ich habe durchaus, glaube ich, Temperaturen, wie sie entstehen bei der Verbrennung
im Motor oder sowas, weil es gibt diese Thermochemiker,
die die untere Atmosphäre von Jupiter modellieren Und die verwenden halt tatsächlich
diese Chemiemodelle, die in der Verbrennung von Gas in Motoren und so weiter ablaufen.
Thermochemie.
Weiter oben nennt man das Ganze Photochemie, weil dort die Energiequelle zum
großen Teil halt tatsächlich die Strahlung der Sonne ist.
Photochemie. Aber weiter unten dringt halt kein Sonnenlicht mehr vor und da
habe ich so eine Thermochemie.
Also ich kann es jetzt gar nicht so genau sagen, weil ich mich tatsächlich mit
dem Inneren des Jupiters gar nicht so gut auskenne. Aber ich kann mir eben durchaus
vorstellen, dass ich dort Temperaturen
im Bereich von 1000, 1500 Grad und wahrscheinlich sogar noch mehr.
Also es ist heiß und es ist dunkel?
Es ist heiß und es ist dunkel.
Okay, das reicht mir auch erstmal. Und würde ich die Gabe haben,
durch dieses heiße, dunkel weiter durchzutreffen, würde ich irgendwann auch
auf was Festes stoßen, in dem Sinne, dass man jetzt nicht nur so von Luftdruck sprechen könnte.
Sondern eben von einer Oberfläche. Ja, eben dieser berühmte metallische Wasserstoff.
Der berühmte metallische Wasserstoff.
Was sind denn jetzt die Ziele, was will man denn jetzt noch herausfinden oder
muss man auch herausfinden, um überhaupt auch ein gutes Verständnis von dem
Gesamtsystem zu bekommen,
was jetzt mit der JUICE-Mission realisiert werden soll, mit den ganzen Instrumentarien,
die dort untergebracht sind.
Wovon können wir denn ausgehen? Was denn so in ein paar Jahren,
wenn dann der Satellit angekommen ist, was wir dann so beobachten werden?
Ich meine, es ist natürlich immer schön zu sagen, was werden wir beobachten?
Weil man fliegt ja deshalb hin, weil man es nicht weiß. Aber es gibt ja schon,
sagen wir mal, eine konkrete Vorstellung davon, wo man hinschauen möchte.
Und man hat ja eine gewisse Vermutung, was dort zu finden ist.
Ja, ich kann ja erstmal anfangen mit dem, was wir mit unserem Instrument machen
wollen, also diesem Submillimeterwelleninstrument.
Dort schauen wir uns natürlich zunächst Jupiter an und wir haben dann äquatorialen
Orbit und sind dort tatsächlich interessiert, hauptsächlich in der mittleren Atmosphäre,
die man bisher nicht so gut analysiert hat oder analysieren könnte.
Und wir messen dort zum einen die molekulare Zusammensetzung,
dann die Zusammensetzung der Isotope, zum Beispiel Wasser, was ich gerade sagte,
aber auch von Komponenten, die Schwefel, Kohlenstoff, Phosphor und so weiter
möglicherweise enthalten.
Und dann messen wir vielleicht Kohlenwasserstoffe, je nachdem,
ob man sie messen kann oder nicht, ob sie da sind oder nicht,
das wissen wir halt nicht.
Wir können aber auch Frequenzen tunen, in denen gewisse Kohlenwasserstoffe vorhanden sind.
Wir messen natürlich Methan, weil wir wissen, Methan ist vorhanden und Methan
ist auch relativ gut durchmischt und deswegen können wir Methan benutzen als
Molekül, mit dem man die Temperaturverteilung in der Mittelatmosphäre messen kann.
Also so ungefähr von 50 Kilometer bis 350 Kilometer oberhalb der Tropopause.
Und sehr wichtig für uns, wir können Winde messen. Also wir können anhand der
Dopplerverschiebung, wie wir es jetzt auch bei diesem Mondvorbeiflug gemacht
haben, sagen, wie groß die Windgeschwindigkeiten dieser Mittelatmosphäre ist.
Und das ist wichtig, weil man zwar aus diesen Klimamodellen oder Atmosphärenmodellen
anhand der Temperaturunterschiede Winde berechnen kann oder vorhersagen kann.
Das hat man auch beim Cassini-Vorbeiflug gemacht. Da hat man also Temperaturstruktur
der Mittelatmosphäre bis 0,1 Millibar gemessen und hat dann anhand dieser Temperaturstrukturen
berechnet, wie dann wohl die Winde dort wehen.
Also man kann sich das vorstellen, vom Hochdruckgebiet fließt ein Wind ins Tiefdruckgebiet
und so weiter, um es jetzt einfach darzustellen.
Es gibt aber eben auch tatsächlich den Einfluss von Wellen, von Wirbeln und
so weiter, die eben auch Energie und Impuls übertragen und die können Winde
teilweise sogar umdrehen, wie wir es aus der Erdatmosphäre kennen.
Also die Frage ist, was ist jetzt der Einfluss von Wellen und Wirbeln?
Die kann man rein anhand von Temperaturmessungen nicht bestimmen.
Wichtig ist also, dass man tatsächlich Temperaturen und Winde gleichzeitig misst.
Und wenn man das macht, kann man damit halt im Endeffekt sagen,
wie funktioniert die Zirkulation überhaupt? Wie wird sie angetrieben?
Und gibt es vielleicht einen großen Antrieb von unten? Eben durch Wellen,
die aus der unteren Atmosphäre in die mittlere Atmosphäre gelangen.
Oder gibt es einen Einfluss des Polarlichtowals?
Dort werden riesige Energiemengen umgesetzt, dadurch, dass diese hochenergetischen
Teilchen in die Atmosphäre eingetragen werden und dort Polarlichter erzeugen.
Oder auch Energie umsetzen in riesigen Mengen, die dann möglicherweise über
Umwege auch wieder in die Atmosphäre, die Energie in die Atmosphäre eingetragen wird.
Dieses Polarlicht oval, das ist ja, wenn ich es richtig sehe,
eine Entdeckung, die Juno erst gemacht hat?
Nein, das wurde schon. Hubble hat das zum Beispiel gesehen und ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher.
Aber es gab jetzt richtig gute Aufnahmen von Juno davon, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Bessere, aber es gab auch schon gute Aufnahmen von Hubble. Also man wusste auch schon,
es gibt halt uralte Aufnahmen von Hubble, indem man halt Polarlichter sieht,
aber Juno hat natürlich vielleicht nochmal mit höherer Auflösung diese Polarlichter aufgenommen.
Ja, also wer das Bild vielleicht nicht vor Augen hat, aber das ist sozusagen,
also der Jupiter hat eine Magnetosphäre, so wie die Erde auch.
Mit anderen Worten, die kosmische Strahlung und was von der Sonne kommt etc.
Trifft nicht gleichförmig auf den Jupiter auf, sondern wird eben von dem Magnetfeld
dann auch in der Polregion quasi umgeleitet, umgesogen und wie auf der Erde
auch entstehen diese Auroren.
Diese Polarlichter, also eine aufglühende Atmosphäre durch diese verdichtete
Strahlung und das tut es auf dem Jupiter halt super extrem.
Also es sieht irgendwie irre aus und dieses Oval ist sozusagen so.
Ist das permanent, ist das immer oder ist das manchmal? Das ist immer, ne?
Genau, also sozusagen der Lichtschalter ist immer an, bei uns muss man die Aurora
dann immer suchen oder Glück haben und da ist sozusagen Dauerbeleuchtung.
Kann man so sagen, ja. Und wie gesagt, die Mengen, die an Energie umgesetzt
werden, sind eben in Größenordnung mehr als zum Beispiel in der Erde und in
der Erdatmosphäre, in der polaren Erdatmosphäre, Junosphäre und so weiter.
Und die Frage ist eben, ist es möglich, dass sozusagen aus dieser Energiequelle
Energie abgezapft wird, die dann die Zirkulation der mittleren Atmosphäre beeinflusst.
Thermosphäre, Stratosphäre, Kopplung sozusagen. Das sind Sachen,
die wir dann messen wollen, indem wir halt die Windgeschwindigkeiten bis eben
in die untere Thermosphäre messen, um zu sehen, dass möglicherweise eine Kopplung
entsteht oder besteht oder nicht.
Und ob es dort Transportphänomene gibt, generell halt zu verstehen,
wie funktioniert da diese Zirkulation überhaupt.
Bisher gibt es da halt viel Spekulation und wir wissen halt ein bisschen was
über den Transport durch Schumacher-Levy 9, aber so richtig wissen wir halt
nicht, wie die Zirkulationssysteme dort funktionieren.
Das ist eben eine große Fragestellung, die wir haben jetzt speziell mit unserem
Instrument, weil wir unter anderem eben halt Temperaturen und gleichzeitig Winde messen können.
Und anhand dieser Parameter tatsächlich die Modelle dann, den Modellen halt
Randbedingungen liefern können.
Um zu sehen, ob jetzt diese Vorhersage oder jene Vorhersage korrekt ist oder
keine, das vielleicht ganz anders funktioniert.
Das heißt im Idealfall...
Den wünscht man sich ja immer, man weiß es ja nicht, aber im Idealfall würde
man eigentlich einen ganz neuen Blick auf den Jupiter gewinnen,
weil man das erste Mal nachweisen kann,
wie diese Strömungen tatsächlich sind und es nicht nur quasi so in zweiter Ordnung
nachgerechnet hat mit das, was wir da sehen, könnte in etwa auf das und das
passen, weil mein Simulationssystem hat gesagt,
das könnte Winde dieser Art ergeben, sondern diesmal werden wir das erste Mal
wirklich den Fühler reinhalten und sagen so,
ja, das ist jetzt mal hier genauso schnell und jetzt könnt ihr mal eure Modelle
überarbeiten, weil das ist ja dann auch immer so ein Spiel in der Raumfahrt und Wissenschaft,
dass man sagt, okay, auf der einen Seite haben wir eben viele Modelle,
wir können viel vorhersagen, das ist ja auch eine wichtige Nahrung,
um überhaupt auch erstmal solche Missionen auf bestimmte Ziele hin zu optimieren,
Aber in dem Moment, wo man es dann eben auch wirklich konkret messen kann,
ist das ja dann auch wieder eine Feedbackschleife für die Simulationen,
die dann eben sagen, ja okay gut, wir hatten es im Prinzip richtig,
aber diesen Aspekt haben wir offensichtlich nicht genug gewichtet oder überhaupt
nicht bedacht, sodass ja dann in der
Zukunft dann wiederum auch die Simulationsmodelle besser werden können,
um eben weitere Voraussagen über den Jupiter oder vielleicht auch andere Planeten,
vielleicht auch Exoplaneten später machen zu können.
Ja genau, das ist eben so eine interessante Frage.
Gibt es dort überhaupt einen Energietransport von unten nach oben oder einen
Impulstransport oder gibt es dort eine Wechselwirkung mit der oberen Atmosphäre,
weil ich dort halt diese riesige Energiequelle habe um den Pole herum und wie
funktioniert das, wie ist eigentlich die Physik dahinter?
Und das kann man natürlich, man kann da jetzt sehr viel spekulieren,
wie das vielleicht sein könnte, aber man braucht im Endeffekt Messdaten dazu,
um dann die verschiedenen Theorien verifizieren zu können oder widerlegen zu können.
Also eigentlich ist der Jupiter noch ein ziemliches Fragezeichen,
so kann man sagen, in der planetaren Forschung.
Jaja, natürlich, sonst wären wir ja nicht hingeflogen. Ja klar,
es gibt ja noch mehr Fragezeichen.
Aber ich meine dafür, dass er so groß ist, würde man ja meinen,
der bietet so viel Beobachtungsfläche, zum wahrsten Sinne des Wortes,
dass die Erkenntnislage da schon besser sein sollte. Aber ist sie nicht.
Nein, ist sie nicht. Aber gut, das ist auch bei anderen Planeten so.
Venus hat man das auch schon vor 50 Jahren analysiert und jetzt gibt es sechs
Venus-Missionen, die bis 2030 starten sollen.
Das ist jetzt auch getrieben durch neue Erkenntnisse. Und bei Jupiter ist es eben so,
dass es eben nach wie vor ein sehr interessanter Planet ist und nachdem man
jetzt naturenintensiv mit Cassini erforscht hat und dort auch viele neue Erkenntnisse gewonnen hat,
möchte man die natürlich auch anwenden für Jupiter und damit dann viele Fragestellungen
möglichst beantworten,
unter anderem auch zum Beispiel wie die Monde entstanden sind.
Ein gutes Stichwort ist Cassini-Huygens, ist ja also auch eine Sonde,
die am Jupiter vorbei geflogen ist, weil sie halt zum Saturn wollte und das
finde ich schon fast ein bisschen absurd, dass man eigentlich so ein bisschen,
vielleicht täusche ich mich auch, aber ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck,
das Saturnsystem ist in gewisser Hinsicht schon mehr erforscht als das des Jupiters,
obwohl es ja nochmal weiter weg ist. Kann man das so sagen?
Kann man so sagen, tatsächlich durch die Cassini.
Durch die Cassini-Mission, genau. Cassini-Huygens hatte ich hier in Raumzeit
auch schon mal erzählt bekommen,
ganz früh schon 2011 mit Michael Kahn von der ESA haben wir über diese Mission
gesprochen, die ja nicht nur jetzt besonders war, weil es halt mit der Cassini-Mission
so eine Langzeitmission der Beobachtung des Saturn-Systems an sich gab und der Monde,
so wie eben Juno auch und eben jetzt auch Drews, sondern eben mit Huygens auch
noch diese Kapsel gab, die ja auf dem Titanenmond abgeworfen wurde.
Etwas Vergleichbares gibt es jetzt für den Jupiter glaube ich noch nicht,
dass man jetzt wirklich mal einem Mond besonders auf die Schliche kommen wollte.
Indem man was abwirft?
Nein, das ist vielleicht was für die Zukunft. Also wäre natürlich sehr interessant,
auf dem Mond Europa zu landen, unter anderem, je nachdem, mit wem man da spricht.
Aber Europa ist natürlich sehr interessant wegen des potenziellen Ozeans oder
diesem sogenannten chaotischen Gelände, chaotic terrain, im Englischen,
wo man irgendwelche Wasserpockets, ich weiß gar nicht, Wassertaschen unter der Oberfläche vermutet.
Und das dann zu analysieren. Das Problem ist aber, dass die Strahlung eben tatsächlich
auf dem Europa so extrem hoch ist, dass es technologisch extrem anspruchsvoll ist,
Geräte zu bauen oder Instrumente zu bauen oder Elektronik zu bauen,
die dort länger als ein, zwei, drei Wochen überlebt.
Ach echt?
Ja, das sind halt diese extrem energiereichen Teilchen, die dort eben über Bremsstrahlung,
unter anderem dann extrem hochenergetische elektromagnetische Strahlung erzeugen,
die dann die Elektronik zerstört.
Wo kommt die Strahlung her?
Also Bremsstrahlung.
Bremsstrahlung.
Ja, das heißt, wenn ich irgendwie ein Teilchen habe, was mit extrem hoher Geschwindigkeit
auf Material trifft, dann entsteht Bremsstrahlung.
Also nicht der Mond strahlt, sondern die Strahlung wird von dem...
Das sind die Teilchen, die da um Jupiter rumfliegen im Endeffekt.
Achso, generell die Jupiter-Strahlung, nicht die von dem Mond aus geht.
Ne, das ist eben die Strahlung, die entsteht durch die Wechselwirkung der extrem
schnell fliegenden Teilchen mit Materie.
Und diese Teilchen werden eingetragen durch Io, durch diese vulkanische Aktivität,
der ungefähr eine Tonne pro Sekunde erzeugt, werden dann ionisiert durch die
Sonne und werden dann im Jupiter-Magnetfeld extrem beschleunigt.
Und dort kann ich halt zum Teil Teilchen, Elektronen mit relativistischen Geschwindigkeiten
antreffen. Und wenn die halt auf Materie treffen, dann führt es eben zu Zerstörung der Elektronik.
Also relativistische heißt sehr hoch.
Sehr hoch, 10.000 Kilometer pro Sekunde.
Und das heißt, das Problem besteht jetzt nicht nur am Europa,
sondern generell, wenn man sich da in dem System bewegt.
Ja, je weiter man nach außen geht, desto geringer wird sozusagen der Beitrag.
Also bei Ganymed ist es nicht mehr ganz so schlimm und bei Callisto ist es noch unproblematischer.
Weil die weiter draußen.
Weil die weiter draußen sind und ursprünglich war es vielleicht auch mal geplant,
anstatt zum Ganymed zu Europa zu fliegen in dieser Mission, also die ist seit 2005 diskutiert.
Und dann ist man aber doch ziemlich schnell zu der Erkenntnis gelangt,
dass mit dem Geld, was man in Europa zur Verfügung hat und mit der Technologie,
das nicht möglich ist, einen Orbiter zu bauen, der jetzt um Europa fliegt.
Das versuchen jetzt die Amerikaner mit Europa Clipper.
Genau, eine geplante Mission, die vielleicht auch irgendwann ein Länder dann
auch haben soll in einer Erfolgemission.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe. Genau, ja das ist so die Idee, dass man tatsächlich,
da gibt es ja viele Studien, dass man auf Europa landet, Löcher bohrt und versucht
zu diesem Ozean vorzudringen.
Da gibt es ja tatsächlich Versuche, habe ich gesehen, Diplom- und Doktorarbeiten,
teilweise sogar auch an deutschen Universitäten.
Allerdings ist das im Moment wohl alles sehr unrealistisch, weil dieses Bohren
allein erfordert extrem viel Energie.
Und ja, da sind wir also wahrscheinlich noch 100, 200 Jahre davon entfernt,
dass die Technologie dafür zur Verfügung steht.
Das würde wahrscheinlich auch bedeuten, dass man Raumfahrzeuge mit irgendeiner
Art von Nuklearantrieb braucht, also Kernspaltung und so weiter,
also Atomkraftwerke an Bord. Da sind wir wieder bei 2001.
Also das ist eben Zukunftsmusik und ja, das ist eigentlich jetzt Science Fiction.
Man überlegt sich zwar, wie man das machen könnte, aber ist einfach technisch
nicht realisierbar und finanziell erst recht nicht. Aber vielleicht in 100 Jahren, wer weiß.
Zukunftsmusik ist ja immer die schönste Musik. Ich meine, es besteht ja jetzt
sozusagen die realistische Chance, dass wir demnächst unseren Helikopterflug
auf dem Titan dann noch anschauen dürfen.
Ich bin da ganz optimistisch, dass da noch eine Menge gehen wird.
Ich würde schon gerne nochmal so ein bisschen auf diese Monde jetzt nochmal
speziell drauf eingehen. Und welche Rolle die spielen.
Jetzt insbesondere mit dem Io, der also diese hohe vulkanische Aktivität hat.
Und wenn ich das jetzt eben richtig verstanden habe, macht der sozusagen richtig
Stress mit seinem Vulkanismus.
Und zwar nicht nur auf sich selber, sondern für das gesamte Jupiter-System durch
diesen hohen Auswurf von Zeug.
Was wirft er denn dann so aus?
Ja, vulkanische Gase, Aerosole, also zum Beispiel SO2 als Beispiel,
aber auch Salze, KCL, NaCl.
Und die werden ausgestoßen eben mit einer Geschwindigkeit, die hoch genug ist,
sodass das schwere Feld des IOS verlassen wird.
Und deswegen verteilt sich das Ganze dann sozusagen im inneren Jupiter-System.
Und Io ist dem Jupiter nächster Mond, also das ist wahrscheinlich auch der Grund
für diesen hohen Vulkanismus, weil der vermutlich von der Gravitation des Jupiter
die ganze Zeit so durchgeweigt wird.
Genau, genau.
Okay und das dankt er sozusagen dem Jupiter durch diesen hohen Auswurf von Zeug
und das flirrt dann herum und zusammen mit der hohen Strahlung,
die ohnehin um den Jupiter herrscht.
Ja, Strahlung selber, die Strahlung wird halt im Endeffekt durch diese Teilchen erzeugt.
Also der Jupiter selber strahlt natürlich nicht als Planet selber,
sondern eben hervorgerufen durch die Wechselwirkung der Teilchen mit dem Starkmachnetfeld
und der Ionisation dieser Teilchen durch die Sonnenstrahlung.
Also es ist ein totales Chaos da oben.
Ja, es ist zumindest eine unwirtliche Umgebung.
Das gibt Schülerexperimente, also diese Wechselwirkung, die ich da jetzt kurz angesprochen habe,
führt unter anderem dazu, dass eben nicht nur im UV und im sichtbaren Polarlichter
und im Infraroten riesige Mengen an Energie umgesetzt wird, sondern auch im Radiowellenbereich.
Und man kann mit einem Kurzwellenempfänger sozusagen Jupiter,
wenn er über den Horizont kommt, empfangen.
Da hört man so komisches Knistern und Knacken und so weiter.
Das sind halt tatsächlich Signale, die in einem extrem breiten Spektralbereich
von ULF bis ins UV oder Gammastrahlung abgestrahlt werden.
Und ja unter anderem zum Beispiel eben durch das,
Polarlicht, aus dem Polarlicht oval heraus oder generell durch die Wechselwirkung
mit dem Manetfeld starke Mikrowellenstrahlung stattfindet und so weiter und so fort.
Das heißt was da an Energie umgesetzt wird ist also deutlich mehr als bei allen
anderen Planeten im Sonnensystem zusammen und das ist von daher eine ganz interessante Geschichte.
Also Io macht Alarm und ist sozusagen der vulkanische Mond und ist auch überhaupt der nächste.
Also der erste, der sozusagen überhaupt… Der innerste Mond, ja.
Genau, dem folgt ein Europa, der ist nicht ganz so durchgeweigt,
deswegen offensichtlich auch keine vulkanische Aktivität, aber wahrscheinlich
immer noch genug Einfluss, um den in irgendeiner Form in Bewegung zu halten.
Ja, vulkanische Aktivität ist so die Frage. Auf Island hat man ja Geysire und
man glaubt ja auch mindestens drei Anzeichen eines großen Geysirs auf Europa entdeckt zu haben.
Da gibt es halt zwei Hubble-Messungen und einmal Messungen vom Erdboden aus,
von Hawaii aus im Infraroten.
Dort glaubt man tatsächlich Geysire entdeckt zu haben, die etwa 2000 Tonnen
Wasser in die Umgebung von Europa geschleudert haben.
So pro Spritzer.
Pro Spritzer kann man so sagen, ja. Und gut, das Ganze ist so ein bisschen fragwürdig,
weil die Signale, von denen man da spricht, sind meistens so 3,3 bis 3,5 Sigma.
Das kennt man ja auch vom Higgs-Boson, dass man gesagt hat, bevor wir keine
Fünf-Sigma-Detektion haben, glauben wir das nicht.
Das ist jetzt so die Frage, das ist natürlich eine sehr interessante Fragestellung,
weil wenn es tatsächlich diese Geysire geben würde,
da hat man halt Wasser gemessen, weil Wasser noch, also von Hubble zum Beispiel,
noch am einfachsten zu messen ist, weil es halt sehr, sehr stark absorbiert bzw. imitiert.
Dann gibt es vielleicht auch andere Gase, die dort vorkommen.
Also wenn tatsächlich so ein Geysir jetzt Wasser aus dem Inneren,
im Idealfall von dem Ozean, meinetwegen in 10 Kilometer Tiefe in die Atmosphäre
schleudert, dann werden ja möglicherweise auch noch alle anderen Moleküle mitgerissen.
Und kann man vielleicht die molekulare Zusammensetzung im Wasser bestimmen?
Und da gibt es dann diese berühmte Frage nach diesem Schnopps,
also C-A-O-N-P-S, also das sind die sogenannten essentiellen Elemente für Lebensfreundlichkeit.
Neuntlichkeit, also Schnopps, C-A-O-M-P-S, so kann man sich das am leichtsten merken.
Kohlenstoff, Wasserstoff, Stickstoff, Sauerstoff, Phosphor und Schwefel.
Richtig. Und da ist dann die Frage, also für uns zum Beispiel,
wir können unser Instrument so auf hunderte von Spektrallinien einstellen und
knapp hundert verschiedene Moleküle oder tausende von Übergängen im Endeffekt.
Da ist dann die Frage, finden wir tatsächlich Moleküle, die eins dieser Elemente enthält?
Und falls tatsächlich wir feststellen sollten, dass diese Aktivität existiert,
werden wir natürlich dann unsere Empfänger auf Moleküle tunen,
die dann möglicherweise da gefunden werden oder auch nicht.
Aber ist denn Europa nicht schon beobachtet worden von Galileo und von Juno?
Da muss man doch irgendwie was gesehen haben.
Also wenn man sich jetzt hier nur auf Hawaii beruft, wundere ich mich ja,
warum man nicht schon mal näher hingeschaut hat.
Ja, das ist eben die Idee, warum man halt diese neuartigen Instrumente baut,
die halt viel höhere Empfindlichkeit ermöglichen und liefern als eben die mehr
in Anführungsstrichen klassischen wie Infrarot-Experimente.
Im Endeffekt kommt es bei dieser Spektroskopie immer darauf an,
dass man eine sehr, sehr hohe spektrale Auflösung hat.
Einfach deswegen, weil die Spektrallinien selber da in dieser Situation im mehr
oder weniger Vakuum extrem schmal sind.
Und ich muss die auflösen können, damit ich die entsprechende Empfindlichkeit habe.
Wenn ich ein normales Gitterspektrometer oder FTS im Infrarot nehme,
habe ich vielleicht Auflösungen von 5.000, 10.000, wenn es hochkommt und damit
kann ich diese Linien nicht auflösen.
10.000 was, so einzelne Linien?
Also das ist praktisch das Frequenzintervall oder die Frequenz geteilt durch
das Frequenzintervall. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel, was weiß ich.
Ein Terahertz, sage ich jetzt einfach mal, 10 hoch 12 Hertz als Frequenz des
Moleküls habe und löse das auf mit einem Megahertz,
dann ist das 10 hoch 12 geteilt durch 10 hoch 6, dann habe ich eine Auflösung von einer Million.
Und um alle Linien sicher auflösen zu können, braucht man etwa so 10 Millionen Auflösung.
Das heißt, je höher ich in der Frequenz gehe, desto schlechter muss jetzt die
absolute Auflösung sein, damit ich das Ganze erreiche.
Die normalen Gitterspektrometer oder so oder Fourier-Transform-Spektrometer
im Paroten, die so fliegen, haben meistens Auflösungen 1000,
maximal 5000, vielleicht 10.000.
Wenn man eine höhere Auflösung haben will, dann werden sie sehr groß und schwer
und schwierig zu fliegen. Also am Boden habe ich durchaus diese Art von Spektrometern.
Ich stelle Spektrometern bis Auflösung von vielleicht 100.000.
Aber die kann man halt nicht so ohne weiteres fliegen. Und deswegen haben wir
eine andere Methode angewandt. Das nennt sich Heterodynspektroskopie,
mit der ich halt 10 Millionen erreiche.
Und dadurch erreiche ich eben die extrem hohe Empfindlichkeit,
weil ich die Linien tatsächlich auflöse.
Und deswegen hoffen wir eben, dass wir Moleküle sehen können,
die man vorher nicht sehen konnte, weil die Empfindlichkeit einfach fehlte.
Wir haben zum Teil tausendfach höhere Empfindlichkeit als das,
was man da vorher geflogen ist.
Also man war schon da, aber man hatte einfach noch nicht das Instrumentarium,
durch Juice wird jetzt alles besser. Genau.
Als Beispiel, man hat jetzt halt, von Hubble beziehungsweise vom Boden aus,
eine Empfindlichkeit sowas von, also man hat 2000 Tonnen gemessen mit einer
Empfindlichkeit vielleicht von 600 Tonnen, also 3, irgendwas Sigma.
Und wenn wir dort sind, haben wir dann eine Empfindlichkeit,
die ist meinetwegen 10 Kilogramm oder 1 Kilogramm. Also wir sind da in fünf
Größenordnungen empfindlicher.
Das heißt, wenn da irgendwas rumschwirrt an Geysieren und so weiter,
selbst im ganz kleinen Bereich sehen wir das sofort.
Und deswegen ist es auch so, wenn wir um Jupiter herumfliegen in der Anfangsphase,
wollen wir jeden Tag eine Stunde
die Monde beobachten, ob es da irgendeine atmosphärische Aktivität gibt.
Wir können die Monde aus Entfernung von einigen Millionen Kilometern beobachten
und trotzdem noch die Atmosphäre entsprechend nachweisen.
So, das heißt, wir haben jetzt Io und Europa schon ein wenig gewürdigt.
Ganymed und Callisto sind dann die anderen von den vier großen.
Alle außer Io gelten quasi als Eismonde.
Also heißt das, dass sie im Wesentlichen aus Wasser bestehen oder nennt man
sie Eismonde, weil sie so kalt sind?
Nee, weil wohl der Anteil von leichteren Elementen und Wasser unter anderem
relativ gesehen zu Io größer ist.
Also insgesamt ist es ja so, dass die Dichte von innen nach außen abnimmt.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht auswendig, aber ich meine, Io hat eine Dichte von 3,6.
Ich glaube Europa von 3 und dann Ganymed von 1,8 und so weiter.
Also die werden immer leichter sozusagen von innen nach außen.
Das ist so Gramm pro Kubikzentimeter.
Genau, oder Tonnen pro Kubikmeter.
Ja, das geht von 3,5 bis 1,8, wenn ich das hier richtig sehe.
Okay, aber so Ganymed und Kalusso haut dich jetzt nicht so vom Hocker,
ist nicht so interessant?
Doch, ich meine natürlich haut mich das vom Hocker.
Weil… Ich spüre die Begeisterung noch nicht so richtig.
Ja, ja, ja, natürlich finde ich das auch sehr interessant.
Ich meine, wie gesagt, diese Frage der Lebensfreundlichkeit,
Habitability im Englischen, ist natürlich auch eine große Frage,
Aber damit haben wir eigentlich gar nicht angefangen, sondern da geht es auch
wieder um grundsätzliche Fragestellungen.
Ganymede ist auch ein sehr breites Gebiet, ein sehr breites Thema und wir speziell
interessieren uns für die Exosphäre oder die Atmosphäre.
Und zwar, es gibt dort wohl eine Atmosphäre, man hat Sauerstoff gemessen,
man hat CO2 gemessen, man hat Wasser gemessen.
Aber da gibt es zum Beispiel die Frage, wie funktioniert die Atmosphäre überhaupt?
Was sind die Quellen der Atmosphäre?
Was führt dazu, dass dort eine Atmosphäre existiert? Wodurch entsteht die?
Und nächste Frage ist dann, was passiert mit dieser Atmosphäre?
Sind dort Dichten vorhanden in der Unternehmensphäre, die hoch genug sind?
Dass sie stoßdominiert ist, dass ich dort wirklich von der Atmosphäre sprechen
kann oder habe ich sowas ähnliches wie jetzt um den Satelliten herum,
wie ich vorhin gesagt habe, dass die Moleküle kaum Möglichkeit haben zu stoßen.
Das kann ich tatsächlich in einer Art von dynamischem Modell anwenden,
um das zu modellieren oder ist das eine rein kinetische Atmosphäre,
meinetwegen eine ballistische Atmosphäre, wo irgendwo aus dem Boden Material
in Form von Gas nach oben geschleudert wird und dann irgendwo anders wieder runterfällt.
Und wir können dann halt, wie gesagt, wiederum die Dichte messen,
wie viele Moleküle sind vorhanden, mit welcher Geschwindigkeit verlassen sie
den Boden, in welche Richtung wird dieser Wind in Anführungsstrichen geblasen.
Das sind also viele grundsätzliche Fragestellungen, Messungen,
die man bisher so noch nie gemacht hat.
Jedenfalls nicht bei Monden, vielleicht bei Kometen, Miro, Rosetta.
Aber andere Frage sind dann wiederum die isotopische Zusammensetzung.
Wir wissen, dort ist Wasser, wir wissen, wir sind sehr empfindlich.
Wir können diese Wasseratmosphäre sehr genau charakterisieren und wir können
eben auch sagen, wie das Wasser wiederum sich zusammensetzt und daraus Rückschlüsse
ziehen, wie der Mond entstanden ist und wo er entstanden ist.
Ist der Mond sehr schnell entstanden bei sehr, sehr hohen Temperaturen,
was darauf hindeutet, dass wir wahrscheinlich ein sehr niedriges Dezuharverhältnis
im Wasser sehen würden oder ist er sehr langsam entstanden und weiter außen.
Und wenn er sehr langsam entsteht, kann man davon ausgehen, dass die Temperaturen,
die bei der Entstehung entstanden sind, in der Scheibe um Jupiter herum niedriger
sind, weil der Energieumsatz entsprechend geringer war beziehungsweise die Wärmestrahlung
dazu geführt hat, dass das System mehr gekühlt wurde und so weiter und so fort.
Man kann halt anhand der isotopischen Zusammensetzung der Gase,
die man dort sieht, Wasser wird man auf jeden Fall sehen, vielleicht sieht man
auch noch andere Gase, eben Aussagen darüber machen, wie der entsprechende Mond,
Und also Ganymed zum Beispiel in diesem Fall entstanden ist.
Das ist also eine völlig andere Fragestellung als diese der Habitabilität,
die auch interessant ist.
Und man kann auch nicht ausschließen, dass es möglicherweise Geysir oder sowas
ähnliche Phänomene auch im Ganymed gibt.
Wie gesagt, wir haben hier mindestens tausendfache Empfindlichkeit gegenüber
allem, was man bisher hatte.
Das heißt, wir werden auch sehr kleine und sehr schwache lokale Prozesse sehen können.
Und es ist ja so, dass die JUICE-Mission dann irgendwann in einen polaren Orbit
um Ganymed einschwenkt.
Erst 5000, dann schließlich 500 Kilometer im Durchmesser.
Das heißt, man ist sehr nah dran und kann dann halt hochpräzise atmosphärische
Messungen mit sogenanntem Limp-Scanning durchführen,
indem man manchmal den Höhenbereich von 0 bis 500 Kilometern immer abscannt
und dort dann halt Windetemperaturen und Dichten der Atmosphäre bestimmt,
beziehungsweise molekulare Zusammensetzung.
Und das ist für uns jetzt eben von sehr großem Interesse, weil es ist also relativ exotisch.
Titan hat ja eine sehr dichte Atmosphäre mit 1,5 Bar am Boden und hier sprechen
wir eben über Atmosphären, die so etwa der Erdatmosphäre in 90,
100 Kilometern Höhe entsprechen.
Aber wie gesagt, bei der Erdatmosphäre wissen wir ja, wie die entstanden ist
und wie die funktioniert und da wissen wir das überhaupt nicht.
Also wir wissen überhaupt nicht, wie gesagt, was die Prozesse sind,
die überhaupt dazu führen, dass ich dort Gase habe.
Also ist es Sublimation, die Sonne scheint praktisch einfach auf den Mond und
führt dann dazu, dass Eis sublimiert oder sind es diese hochenergetischen Teilchen, Sputtering,
die also dazu führen, dass dort Gasmoleküle die Oberfläche verlassen oder Radiolyse
und das sind alles so die verschiedenen Theorien, die es dort gibt.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn wir auf Europa zurückkommen als Beispiel.
Dort haben wir bisher eine Empfindlichkeit von 600 Tonnen und da kommen wir
vielleicht auf, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ich muss jetzt nochmal genau nachreichen,
aber vielleicht 600 Mikrogramm Empfindlichkeit.
Was heißt das 600 Mikrogramm Empfindlichkeit? Was ist da empfindlich?
Wenn da jetzt so ein Plum rauskommt, also so ein Geysir,
da hat man bisher halt drei bis dreieinhalb Sigma-Detektionen von 2000 Tonnen
gehabt und wir würden Geysire sehen, die da vielleicht eine Masse haben,
anstatt von 2000 Tonnen von ein paar Mikrogramm.
Okay, das ist schon mal eine Ansage.
Ja, das sind also, wie gesagt, jetzt als Beispiel.
Also vorher hat man gesehen, dass da überhaupt irgendwas ist und jetzt würde
man es schon sehr feinfühlig messen können.
Genau, von daher war dieser Mondvorbeiflug ganz interessant.
Da hatten wir eigentlich eine
sogenannte Säulendichte von 2 mal 10 hoch 17 Molekülen pro Quadratmeter.
Das sind etwa 7 Größenordnungen weniger als ein Mol Wasser. Ein Mol Wasser sind 18 Gramm.
Das sind 6 mal 10 hoch 23 und hier sprechen wir von 2 mal 10 hoch 17.
Und da konnten wir richtig dicke Linien sehen. Also in Wirklichkeit haben wir
noch eine Impflichkeit, die etwa 3, 4 Größenordnungen darunter liegt.
Und ja, das ist eben das Interessante, man sieht da fast nichts.
Also extrem geringe Mengen werden wir dort aufspülen können.
Und das kann man natürlich auch mit Massenspektrometern und Massenspektrometer
sind ja auch in der Vergangenheit geflogen und dadurch bekannt,
dass sie eben sehr, sehr geringe Mengen von Stoffen, teilweise auch unbekannten
Stoffen, die man dann erst identifizieren muss, finden können.
Aber dazu muss man natürlich durch so eine Wolke oder durch eine Atmosphäre durchfliegen.
Und das ist ja nicht so einfach.
Wenn man weiß, dass dort irgendwie eine Aktivität ist, kann man vielleicht mal
Glück hat, die Trajektöre des Satelliten zu ändern, dass man da mal irgendwann
durchfliegt, wie zum Beispiel bei Enceladus.
Aber wir können das eben halt aus der Entfernung machen. Wir können eben aus
großer Entfernung bis zu 1, 2, 3, 5 Millionen Kilometer Entfernung diese Zusammensetzung bestimmen.
Das ist halt das Neue und eben auch mit extrem hoher Empfindlichkeit.
Von daher ist es eben für uns eben doch, allein diese, ich meine das hört sich jetzt sehr speziell an.
Tatsächlich diese Exosphären genau analysieren zu wollen oder zu können.
Aber es ist eben, bisher weiß man nicht viel.
Und das wird uns die Augen öffnen. Wir werden komplett neue Erkenntnisse gewinnen.
Diese Monde, von denen wir sprechen,
sind ja auch alle so in etwa in der Größenordnung unseres Mondes.
Bisschen kleiner, bisschen größer. Aber auch Titan ist ja auch alles so in derselben
Größenordnung. Also würden die jetzt quasi um die Erde herumschwimmen,
die wären am Himmel so in etwa in derselben Größenordnung.
Verwundert das eigentlich so ein bisschen, dass bei so einem Riesenteil wie
Jupiter die Monde auch nur so vergleichsweise kleine Kleckse sind?
Oder ist das jetzt einfach nur so eine spezifische Erdgeschichte,
weil wir hier davon ausgehen, dass der Mond dann doch im Wesentlichen wahrscheinlich
aus der Erde heraus geschlagen wurde und deshalb relativ groß ist?
Ja, ich denke, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Zufall. Also wie gesagt,
der Erdmond ist ja durch diesen Einschlagkörper teilweise höchstwahrscheinlich entstanden,
was man allein schon an der eben tatsächlich isotopischen Zusammensetzung der
Materialien des Mondes weiß.
Die ist praktisch identisch mit dem, was wir auf der Erde sehen.
Und man kann davon ausgehen, dass die Monde des Jupiters also völlig anders
entstanden sind, sondern nämlich aus einer Gaswolke, die in der Umgebung des
Jupiters in irgendeiner Form vorhanden war.
Es ist mehr so eine Resteverwertung als ein großer kosmischer Unfall.
Könnte man vielleicht so bezeichnen, ja.
Da muss man sich ja auch mal klar machen, das haben wir glaube ich auch hier
beim Gespräch um das Saturnsystem gemacht, Jupiter ist ja eigentlich so groß,
er ist ja so ein bisschen schon fast so ein verhinderter Stern.
Also der ist ja sehr groß und sehr schwer und alles und so weiter,
aber es ist halt jetzt einfach so ein Gasriese ein großer Planet,
aber es hätte jetzt auch nicht mehr so sehr viel mehr gebraucht, um das Ding auch,
selber zu zünden also ein bisschen mehr schon, aber ist ja,
schon so, also ich weiß nicht, sehr viel größere Planeten gibt es glaube ich
dann auch sonst gar nicht mehr oder?
Doch, denke ich schon, also wenn man sich im Sonnensystem natürlich nicht,
aber Wenn man sich Exoplaneten anschaut, gibt es auch durchaus größere.
Bis zum Faktor was ungefähr?
Das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber ich meine, das wäre ja sehr unwahrscheinlich,
dass Jupiter allein von der Statistik her der größte Planet wäre.
Es gibt sicherlich diese heißen Jupiter. Im Endeffekt ist es so,
dass es verschiedene Kategorien von Planeten gibt. Die nennt man dann eben Jupiter
oder nennt man Neptun anhand der Masse und der Größe.
Aber ich bin überzeugt, dass es also deutlich größere Planeten gibt,
weil wie groß ein Planet ist, hängt ja im Endeffekt davon ab,
wie viel Material in der Protoplanetanscheibe, aus dem er entstanden ist,
vorhanden war. Aber es gibt wahrscheinlich Planeten, die zehnmal so groß im Durchmesser sind.
Ja, aber wenn sie dann eine gewisse Masse haben, dann zünden sie ja dann vielleicht
auch irgendwann, wenn sie sich zusammenklappen.
Ja, kommt dann auch auf die Zusammensetzung an. Klar, wenn es nur Wasserstoff ist.
Auf jeden Fall spielt der Jupiter ja im Sonnensystem auch eine besondere Rolle.
Nicht nur, weil er jetzt der Größte ist, sondern weil er durch seine Masse ja
auch das Gesamtsystem ordentlich durcheinander bringt.
Also wir haben ja den Merkur, die Venus, uns, die Erde, dann halt den Mars und
dann passiert ja erstmal eine ganze Weile lang nichts, beziehungsweise passiert
ja eigentlich eine ganze Menge, weil wir ja diesen riesigen Asteroidengürtel haben.
Und da fliegt ja auch eine ganze Menge Zeug rum, aus dem ja nie ein Planet geworden ist.
Und der Grund dafür ist der Jupiter, weil er einfach mit seiner Gravitation
so viel Ärger macht, dass sich einfach diese Asteroiden nie so richtig haben
zusammenfinden können.
Ist denn das ein geklärter Bereich oder kann man jetzt mit diesen Missionen,
die wir dorthin schicken, auch aus diesem Bereich des Asteroidengürtels noch
irgendwelche Erkenntnisse gewinnen?
Schaut man da einfach nochmal auf irgendwas drauf oder ist das alles schon kalter
Kaffee, interessiert keinen mehr?
Ne, das ist natürlich kein kalter Kaffee, aber ich glaube rein aus praktischen
Gründen wird man jetzt mit der Juice-Mission keine Asteroiden untersuchen können,
einfach weil man nicht genug Treibstoff hat.
Also man wählt eine Trajektüre natürlich hauptsächlich danach,
um mit möglichst viel Energie dort anzukommen und wenn man Glück hat,
liegt dann auf dem Weg irgendwie ein Asteroid, den man sich anschauen kann.
Es ist mal tatsächlich diskutiert worden, ob man die Bahn nicht ein bisschen
ändern kann, um dort irgendwelche Untersuchungen zu machen.
Das ist aber im Endeffekt verhofft worden. Was natürlich nicht heißt,
dass jetzt die Erforschung des Asteroidengürtels nicht interessant wäre.
Das ist natürlich an sich schon interessant.
Und nach wie vor, also zum Beispiel ein interessantes Gebiet,
was mir gerade so einfällt, sind die sogenannten Mainbelt-Kometen.
Also Asteroiden, die tatsächlich so eine Art Kometenschweif hinter sich herziehen.
Und die Frage ist, wie kommt das überhaupt dazu?
Weil man ja glaubt, dass Kometenschweife entstehen durch Ausgasen,
zum Beispiel von Wasser oder anderen Molekülen, die dann sozusagen den Staub
an der Oberfläche mit sich mitreißen.
Man hat aber erst bei einem dieser Mainbelt-Kometen, ich glaube letztes Jahr
oder vorletztes Jahr, mit dem James-Webb-Teleskop letztes Jahr überhaupt Wasser
entdecken können, während zig andere Messungen nichts gefunden haben.
Das ist die Frage. Was sind eigentlich die Prozesse, die dann dazu führen,
dass tatsächlich so ein Staubschweif entsteht?
Ist das vielleicht ein völlig anderer Prozess als Ausgasen? Das ist natürlich
auch noch eine von vielen Fragen.
Dann gibt es natürlich die Leute, die interessiert wären, die Zusammensetzung
des Oberflächenmaterials sich anzuschauen. also Sample Return,
Um dann mit viel höherer Genauigkeit.
Da gibt es ja eine Menge Missionen, vor allem die Amerikaner und die Japaner ganz eifrig dabei.
Hayabusa, genau, Osiris Rex.
Und ja, dann eben die Frage der Asteroiden im äußeren Asteroidengürtel, der Kohlenkondriten,
wie viele Organe des Materiales vorhanden ist, wie ist die genaue Zusammensetzung,
wie viel Wasser ist dort vorhanden.
Was genau bezeichnet man als den äußeren und den Hauptgürtel?
Wir reden jetzt schon noch immer nur von dem Bereich zwischen Mars und Jupiter,
der teilt sich nochmal in verschiedene Bereiche.
Ja, verschiedene, die dadurch charakterisiert sind, dass sie eben eine verschiedene
Entfernung von der Sonne haben und deswegen der Solare Fluss,
der Energiefluss der Sonne halt immer weiter abnimmt und es wird halt immer
kälter und irgendwann ist man so, dass ist man in einem Bereich,
wo im Wassereis existieren kann,
während im inneren Bereich das Wassereis eben weg sublimieren würde und somit
auch die Zusammensetzung entsprechend.
Ja, verstehe. Also Asteroid ist nicht gleich Asteroid, sondern hängt schon ein
bisschen davon ab, wo man ist.
Ich bin kein Experte, hängt nicht nur davon ab, wo man ist. Es gibt auch natürlich
an sich kohlige, nicht kohlige Konteriten, es gibt dann Eisenmeteoriten, alles mögliche.
Okay, also aber für Juice ist das erstmal kein Thema. Ist ja eigentlich auch
ganz gut, wenn man einen Weg wählt, wo man jetzt nicht unbedingt mit Asteroiden
kollidieren würde, weil das will man ja dann auch nicht.
Ja, was birgt denn so die Zukunft für den Jupiter?
Also gut, jetzt ist natürlich die Zukunft erstmal Juice und haben wir jetzt
schon gehört, da geht es erstmal hart an die Atmosphäre ran.
Ist dann in Zukunft, geht es dann noch darum,
noch genauer hinzuschauen, Instrumente zu bauen,
die nochmal höhere Frequenzen machen und dann macht man dasselbe einfach nochmal
mit Faktor 10 bis 100 oder wäre es eigentlich so für die Jupiter-Erforschung wichtiger,
dass man mehr auf Lander geht, dass man also wirklich auf die Monde herabsteigt,
dass man irgendwas in den Jupiter rein versenkt.
Wonach schreit das Jupitersystem?
Das möchte doch bestimmt von uns erforscht werden. Was wünscht sich denn der
Jupiter, wie wir uns ihm annähern?
Ja, zunächst muss man sagen, man muss natürlich jetzt erstmal abwarten,
was diese Mission, was Juice zum Beispiel, Euclipa bringt.
Was gibt es an neuen Erkenntnissen? Und ähnlich wie die Cassini-Mission ja Erkenntnisse
zum Beispiel über Enceladus gebracht hat Und jetzt ist geplant,
in der Zukunft Missionen zu entwickeln,
die entweder sehr oft an Enceladus vorbeifliegen oder auf Enceladus sogar landen.
So ähnlich wird es dann auch bei der Jupiter-Mission sein. Ich vermute mal,
es werden neue Erkenntnisse, jede Menge neue Erkenntnisse gewonnen werden und
basierend auf diesen Erkenntnissen wird es Ideen geben, was man als nächstes machen kann.
Die Ideen, dass man jetzt auf den Monden landet und dort irgendwelche Untersuchungen
macht, die sind natürlich trotzdem schon lange da und gerade Europa,
da gab es ja Ideen, sich durch die Eisschicht durchzuschmelzen und dann ein
U-Boot unter der Eisschicht fahren zu lassen, um zu untersuchen, was da so passiert.
In dieser Richtung gibt es natürlich alles mögliche, aber das ist energetisch,
wie gesagt, im Moment nicht möglich.
Dann müsste man zunächst mal ein Atomkraftwerk da oben auf der Oberfläche installieren,
das genügend Energie liefert, damit man sich durch eine 10 Kilometer Eisschicht durchschmelzen kann.
Aber grundsätzlich ist es natürlich, klar, es ist immer interessant,
dass man jetzt zum Beispiel Dragonfly auf Titan landet und dort sich das alles
sehr genau anguckt, wie zum Beispiel ja auch einige Leute.
Also Dragonfly ist der von mir angesprochene Sporber.
Genau, das ist die nächste Frontiersmission, die dann auch viermal so teuer
bisher schon ist, wie sie eigentlich ursprünglich hätte werden sollen.
Und genau wie auf Mars. Sample Return ist eben interessant oder Elon Musk möchte
ja sogar auf Mars landen und dann durch Astronauten die Oberfläche erforschen lassen bzw.
Eine Stadt dort aufbauen. Und wenn natürlich Leute auf dem Mars sind,
sind natürlich die Forschungsmöglichkeiten nochmal wieder ganz andere,
als wenn man das alles remote mit Robotern macht, weil man ja vor Ort sieht,
was da gerade so passiert.
Und von daher kann man sich alle möglichen Sachen ausdenken.
Das meiste sind schöne Gedankenexperimente, weil es praktisch nicht durchführbar
ist aufgrund der Kosten und der nicht vorhandenen Technologie und der nicht
vorhandenen Möglichkeit,
größere Raumschiffe dorthin zu transportieren mit entsprechenden Ressourcen,
die man braucht, um etwas entsprechend aufzubauen.
Nichtsdestotrotz gibt es Vorschläge für eine Vorbeiflugmission von Io.
Also da ist dann die Idee, dass man also relativ tief über die Vulkane fliegt
und dann über Aerogel oder andere Möglichkeiten versucht Material,
was die Vulkaner ausstoßen, also Festkörpermaterial einzufangen.
Wie man das auch schon bei Kometen gemacht hat, dass man hinter dem Kometen
herfliegt und in diesem Aerogel, also in diesem super leichten Stoff,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie soll man den beschreiben, ich habe sowas mit meiner
Hand gehabt, das finde ich bemerkenswert leicht,
also wie so ein super durchsichtiger Schwamm quasi, wo dann halt die kleinen
Teilchen einfach drin hängen bleiben und wenn man das dann wieder zurückführt,
dann kann man eben diese Partikel da sich rauspuppeln.
Genau, das ist vielleicht etwas, was auch schwierig ist, aber vielleicht noch
realisiert werden kann in absehbarer Zeit. Da gab es halt auch Vorschläge.
Aber wie gesagt, so Landen, Sample Return, das sehe ich in nächster Zeit nicht.
Es gibt ja auch Leute, die sehr gerne Sample Return für Venus machen würden,
für die Oberfläche, was wissenschaftlich sicherlich auch sehr interessant ist.
Aber es ist auch technisch sehr anspruchsvoll wegen der hohen Drücke und der hohen Temperaturen.
Und Jupiter ist halt einfach super weit weg, wenn man da wieder zurück muss,
das ist eine lange Reise.
Richtig, richtig. Das ist ja bisher eben überhaupt noch nicht gelungen,
dass man an der Oberfläche landet und dann halt wieder startet.
Das muss man erstmal können und nachweisen, dass es geht.
Das ist ja jetzt für Mars, wird das Ganze diskutiert. Beim Mond hat man das
natürlich gemacht, klar.
Und die Chinesen wollen es ja jetzt auch bei der Tianhe-Ven-3-Mission beim Mars
durchführen, glaube ich sogar bis Ende des Jahrzehnts.
Aber das muss erstmal gelingen und sowas beim Mars zu machen mit einer Atmosphäre,
wo man im Prinzip mit Fallschirmen Energie abbauen kann oder bei einem atmosphärenlosen
Körper, das ist nochmal wiederum eine andere Dimension, also einem Körper mit
Schwerkraft und Atmosphären.
Ohne Atmosphäre ist natürlich, bedeutet man braucht noch mehr Energie und wird
entsprechend schwieriger und teurer.
Alles theoretisch machbar, aber wahrscheinlich nicht darstellbar im Rahmen der
finanziellen Möglichkeiten.
So, jetzt muss ich aber trotzdem noch fragen, was ist dein Lieblingsmond auf
dem Jupiter? Hast du einen?
Äh, ja, ich meine...
Oder sind bei dir alle Kinder gleich?
Also im Moment ist es eigentlich so, ja, ich kann mich nicht so entscheiden
zwischen Ganymed und Europa.
Tatsächlich Ganymed.
Ja, beide haben so, also Ganymed deswegen, weil wir uns halt sehr intensiv damit
beschäftigt haben, wie dann wohl eine solche Atmosphäre überhaupt entstehen
kann und so weiter und so fort.
Und Europa eben, weil da ja angeblich diese Blumes gemessen wurden, diese Geysire.
Und wenn es die wirklich gibt, falls es die geben sollte, interessiert mich
natürlich, wie sind die jetzt molekular zusammengesetzt?
Und haben wir da tatsächlich Zeichen davon, dass es Lebensfreundlichkeit unter dem Eis gibt?
Aber wie realistisch das nun ist, das wissen wir erst, wenn wir dort sind.
Ob es da Aktivität gibt, das ist das Interessante, denn eben wenn wir im Jupiter-Orbit
sind und aus ein paar Millionen Kilometer Entfernung die Monde beobachten können,
dann können wir aus ein paar Millionen Kilometer Entfernung schon sagen,
ob dort tatsächlich irgendeine Aktivität stattfindet. Oder nicht?
Und das Ganze finde ich eben sehr spannend.
Ist da eigentlich Aktivität? Man hat jetzt ein paar Mal von Hubble oder sonst
wie irgendwie was gemessen.
Ist das jetzt permanent vorhanden oder ist das so ein transienter Prozess,
der mit irgendeinem anderen physikalischen Prozess zu tun hat?
Und gibt es tatsächlich so eine Art Tektonik da und dass irgendwann die Platten
so übereinander stehen, dass es Möglichkeiten gibt, dass Wasser von unten an
die Oberfläche gelangt und so weiter und so fort.
Das sind viele interessante Fragen. Für mich persönlich sind diese beiden am
interessantesten natürlich IO im Endeffekt, auch deswegen, weil er permanent
aktiv ist und wir auch aus großer Entfernung die Zusammensetzung dieser Abgasfahnen gemessen können.
Wir haben, wie gesagt, diese Möglichkeit, sehr, sehr viele verschiedene Moleküle
zu sehen und da machen wir dann immer die sogenannten Line-Surveys,
dass man den gesamten Bereich mal durchstimmt und guckt, ob man nicht irgendein
Molekül entdeckt, was vorher noch nicht entdeckt wurde.
Ja, dauert ja alles nicht mehr so lange. In zehn Jahren treten wir schon in
die Umlaufbahn um Ganymed ein. Ist ja quasi morgen.
Naja, die Missionen, also die Ideen fingen 2005 an, also 19 Jahre haben wir
schon hinter uns und die letzten zehn Jahre gehen dann schnell vorbei.
Timeline, ja. Na gut, schauen wir mal.
Ich habe ja schon über so einige Missionen berichtet, die dann irgendwann auch
mal angefangen haben, dort anzukommen.
Demnächst geht es ja dann bei Bibi Colombo zum Beispiel auf der anderen Seite los, etc.
Und das, ja, mal gucken, wie lange ich den Podcast hier noch mache,
dann kriege ich vielleicht die Ergebnisse hier auch nochmal berichtet.
Paul, vielen Dank für die Ausführungen.
Jetzt wissen wir mehr über die atmosphärische Situation am Jupiter,
auch wenn wir noch nicht so richtig viel wissen.
Aber demnächst ein bisschen mehr wissen.
Ja, und ich sage auch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit. Das war's mit der 123.
Und ihr wisst, bald geht es wieder weiter. Bis dahin sage ich Tschüss und bis bald.